foreign
foreign
okay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
he brought some things to light things
that did seem out of sight and now I'd
take it where I go
[Music]
every time I hear that theme song it
makes me wanna sing that catchy catchy
thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll be allowed
will be allowed
[Music]
Alex Jones is
very very upset with me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Shoulders Knees
[Music]
[Music]
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too nonsense okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks alive
[Music]
my mango
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
[Applause]
[Music]
don't want me to me
and highway robbery is what you doing
mangoes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big massive dumps
and bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms well
welcome everybody it is incredible to be
together again for yet another Trump
rally as we are now really getting down
to the wire in a number of different
senses including the 22 midterm election
which is now just what it must be about
one two three four five six uh six weeks
and a few days away this particular
rally is in Wilmington North Carolina it
starts in mere minutes scheduled for 24
minutes from now and we have a packed 24
minutes for you uh between now and then
because I have so many different things
to look for you
um let's see what else and where we want
to start
um I did play the new song maybe I will
say just a little bit about it this is a
really really great piece whoops no
that's for later this one is by our
friend independent n n
oh God we already have trolls here here
God all right the moderators are going
to take care of everything this is a
news we had a we had audio from uh one
of our viewers and then I said well put
together some video and they did they
mapped my face onto different people
let's take a quick look at it it's only
a minute long it's a very very nice
production
[Music]
and this is the the even the melody is
our theme song
modified
there's a story
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anyway you get it so really really
nicely done and super appreciative of
everybody who did the audio elements and
the video elements to that
um I think it's going to be absolutely a
fantastic and beautiful thing all right
let's look at a couple other things here
this video was sent to me actually this
one was sent to me by producer Pat
apparently Dave Rubin cried with
laughter in this video so this must be
I'm sure we will all think one of the
funniest things ever right I mean if it
made Dave Rubin Cry of laughter it must
be super funny let's take a look oh
where's my [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
like that's the beauty of it that's
that's why I [ __ ] but that's why I
loved it because Chris because Chris
could give me the deal that he gave me
and then I could be like yo buddy I'm
[ __ ] the biggest Biden supporter in
the world I'm gonna rep the [ __ ] he
wouldn't give a [ __ ] it's not it's not
about politics no it's about content
entertainment like YouTube is content
entertainment it's for the people it's
like why do we need to get in this adult
politic [ __ ] like long is a [ __ ] like I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah my fans don't
give a [ __ ] about I I mean I I'm
speaking for my fans but I truly believe
that that my fans that are 16 to 30
years old don't truly give a [ __ ] that
much about Paul text like that and the
basing is it sucks that you have to base
the entire world and every tech company
around politics you know not anymore man
not anymore but I just hope I just hope
that it stays that Rumble stays the
thing because you know it's a [ __ ]
War I thought yeah you know like
Rumble could get like I don't know I
don't know we can't get deleted no we
got we got no it's a war so like for you
guys to even go public and do all this
it's like you guys are like kind of
winning that war it's like it's it's
crazy the Insurgency is here yeah so I
hope thank you so much glad to be
partnered with you I'm glad to be on it
I'm glad to make videos all I'd like to
do is get yourself some champagne man
I'm gonna get champagne bot if you guys
watching I'm gonna make videos in like
two to three two to four weeks from now
and it's like I love making videos I
love changing lives uh I'm gonna so far
it's not funny but I'm sure it gets to
the funny part in a moment say this
right now no disrespect to YouTube but
[ __ ] you YouTube no disrespect but like
you banned me for a website that you
allow on your platform like if you're
gonna ban me for a website on my second
Channel like it's 100K like at least and
not allow it on your platform you
[ __ ] communist
[ __ ] like like bammy because I did
something wrong don't ban me for a
[ __ ] pretty electric stuff in.com on
a what on my second Channel like it's
100K views for a website that you
[ __ ] allow you allow this website
we'll just say all right you're gonna be
all right I'm gonna be all right but it
just pisses me off and you know new
opportunity and YouTube you [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you you I
have real fans YouTube you don't have
real fans you're a bunch of commie
bastards [ __ ] you when does the funny
part start I'm so sorry is this live
you know what the beauty about Rumble is
you can make mistakes I like that you're
getting closer to the camera it's like
really you know oh but the thing is you
guys
banned me for a website that you allow
on your platform like let's like let's
let that sink in I hear you man they've
been they've been hitting me for a long
time but imagine like all right we'll
just keeping Rolexes out we'll save for
that is okay
hey my name's YouTube hey buddy how you
doing oh now we're getting to the funny
part guys okay everybody get ready then
that was the funny part
um you can um there's this website
called steak.com you can play it on on
our platform you can show you Planet you
can say hey verbally hey I'm on stake
it's the best gambling website ever you
can say that but if you have that.com
that is [ __ ] bad yeah you are
promoting a bad website yeah you are a
scum bag piece of [ __ ] if they see
that.com you know there's only a minute
left when is the funny part you're gonna
get people to gamble but you know things
you gamble on that website tell them
that you're playing on that website say
where you're playing show them that
you're playing show but if you show
that.com because all these guys are
idiots they don't know how to they don't
know how to get to that website unless
there's the.com they just think steak
like they're gonna think like ribeye
yeah but that's that's what I'm dealing
with makes no sense
so I love you guys this look at the
title
Steve wil dolt makes Reuben cry with
laughter with his epic YouTube rant is
this the rant or is that about a
different video guys I'm probably
getting calls from from my business
partner saying hey you need to chill the
[ __ ] out
but
um I love you guys so much big videos
coming Steve will do videos going live
um I love you guys thank you for so much
for having me thanks brother thank you
so much all right uh
I can't tell there's a screen okay this
is the camera okay I love you guys
Steve will does signing out once a week
oh Steve will do it it looked like a
lowercase L I thought it was Steve wil
dolt
Steve
that was definitely the most colorful uh
thing that has ever happened at NASDAQ
but I think indicative of uh what's
going on over here at Rumble the hole
all right well
I guess it wasn't that fun no it is man
that was that was really weird Okay so
that there was that I hope I apologize
actually for showing that to everybody
that was pretty pretty whacked let's
look at a couple other things our friend
Jason Selvig from the good liars
recently got within proximity of Don
Jr's fiancee
uh Kimberly Guilfoyle and did the uh The
Best Is Yet To Come scream next to her
this is this is I like this
okay I wish I wish we could have seen
what happened after
um but I guess that that's all we got so
I like that that's pretty good
here's J so oh a bunch of you sent me
this video clip this is really
interesting this is Jared Kushner
on Fox News criticizing Ron desantis's
Martha's Vineyard stunt now I'm going to
tell you guys what this is actually
about okay oh then there's super chats
we're going to get to those in a moment
it's not that Jared Kushner is against
the Martha's Vineyard stunt on principle
it's that the campaign against DeSantis
is starting so Kushner has to start
hitting DeSantis for different things
and this is one of them so check this
out I also we have to remember these are
human beings they're people so seeing
them being used as political pawns one
way or the other is is very uh troubling
to me yeah so empathetic right so
morally upstanding guys all he cares
about is this is an opportunity to
criticize Ron DeSantis because Ron
DeSantis and Donald Trump may be facing
off that's all that this is about
all right so we got that and then I
tweeted this one earlier a mom at the
Republican
um commitment to America agenda rollout
said that anti-bullying is an example of
Marxism
let that sink in there are many other
public education issues concerning
parents like myself yeah the slow creep
of critical race Theory diversity equity
and inclusion
gender identity and allowing biological
boys to enter girls spaces and sports
right
now we have SEL which is social
emotional learning Oh I thought you said
SEO search engine optimization
it's indoctrination disguised as promo
programs like kindness initiatives or
anti-bullying programs or diverse very
dangerous anti-bullying City projects
these are all marks of style programs
yeah really really Marxist very very
much so targeting our children
um
yeah so
um that's that's a lot that's a lot
right there it's Marxism okay let me now
re-welcome everybody I do want to say
welcome welcome welcome we are just 15
minutes away from the start of tonight's
Trump rally we are awaiting the failed
former president Donald Trump in
Wilmington North Carolina this is in
theory a rally to support other people
who are on the ballot in November but
usually it's all about Trump and if any
of you saw some of our video clips this
week you saw Donald Trump a very very
scared visibly scared particularly in
that weird interview with Fox News
propaganda Sean Hannity and so we will
see what happens when Trump shows up
today I'm going to give you some video
clips from the rally in a moment
um some of the attendees and different
things we'll see if Mike pillow is there
and we're going to look at all of it
super super strongly if you're just uh
if this is your first time joining a
live stream everyone is welcome you will
be banned if you troll the live chat
with anything that is you know not
fostering a good community so
anti-Semitism will get you banned
transphobia racism xenophobia all these
things will get you banned everyone's
welcome to watch but you've got to
behave in the chat and that applies on
YouTube that applies on Twitch and that
applies on Facebooks as well all of it
it applies and exists Pappy asks do you
think Joe manchin would let the
government shut down if he doesn't get
his side deal pipeline in a stopgap
funding bill no I don't believe he would
Papi
uh other super chats and I know I missed
a few
um thankfully our dear leader Trump has
the biggest most beautiful a brain and
preemptively telepathically Declassified
the documents planted by the FBI yeah
you know if Trump can declassify
documents telepathically as he so
claimed the other day can Biden classify
documents telepathically I mean it seems
only natural
that that's something that could be done
okay let me say some thank yous I want
to say thanks to Johnny manogue and
Kevin gouldi for gifting subscriptions
on my website joinpakman.com putting us
at two very much appreciate that I want
to thank people who have been signing up
via twitch including do you grock John
Trisha RAR bear Andrew Mays Thug
Chuckles r thader pink and blonde tuge
Bowflex Man guitar goddess symbolistic
Punk on a bike chai Town dude and Ms
frazzled putting us at 13. the goal is a
hundred
and I think we're going to be able to do
that tonight okay so I appreciate
everybody who has been calling in let's
now dump in one voicemail just for
flavor and then we're gonna move on to
other things
so I noticed that the place with the
like a really good amount of Jewish
people
don't want to attacked Greece during the
Holocaust
um oh boy I noticed that it seemed like
uh
over in Italy there was like some sort
of like a really slow invasion of Irish
people and we're gonna get away from
that I think I've roughly had enough of
that and we are going to be
um we're going to be moving on okay
let's look at a couple other things we
have here we are monitoring events on
the ground in Wilmington North Carolina
let's see what we have uh I have a lot
of different things here only some of
them relevant to us today
let me get to the relevant ones for us
oh earlier at the rally when Joe Biden's
name was mentioned the crowd chanted
lock him up these people claim to be
about Law and Order but locking up a guy
not even suspected of a crime is not
exactly due process and he wants to hire
87 000 more IRS agents to treat all of
these Working Families like tax cheats
come on folks
[Music]
yeah
look
[Applause]
pretty clever huh the party of Law and
auto I'm sorry Law and Order says lock
up a guy
who is trying to catch tax cheats now by
the way very important the entire 87 000
IRS agents thing
um 55 000 IRS agents are expected to
retire over the next decade
and part of the 87 000 is just to
replace the 55 000 over the next decade
doesn't sound quite as scary
when you put it in those terms
it doesn't sound quite as scary when you
put it in those terms but why let the
truth get in the way of a good scare
tactic James says sir I'm coming to you
with tears in my eyes to ask is it
possible Obama Declassified Hillary's
emails Obama with his brain and never
told anyone sure Obama might have might
have telepathically done it are you
taking calls David no
David can we get a dose of prompts
mispronunciations and ramblings let's
see what I have here for us
um my trump file
where are some of my uh
mispronunciations no teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender
transition
s
yeah
I I'm actually my my sound board is
completely messed up
where is my soundboard hold on audio
Trump
where is where is all my stuff Max
silicone I don't care what that name is
name it peaches peaches yeah these are
all messed up
they call them dumps yeah
all right I'm gonna have to reorganize
my soundboard soon I I'm sorry I can't
do any better than that today thanks to
Adam Cortez for signing up at
joinpakman.com folks today's coupon code
is indict you know why it's in diet it's
because it's time to indict we all know
that okay the coupon code is in Diet I
would love for you to use it let's look
at a few more things here from on the
ground in Wilmington North Carolina uh
let's see what else we have
oh this is funny look listen to this
level of delusion
president Trump I'd be the first
president that actually delivered on
now that's actually funny
the wall didn't get built
the beautiful replacement to Obamacare
was never even proposed never mind made
law
the israeli-palestinian conflict was not
solved you know how long can I really do
this I'm not going to do this the entire
stream
but okay so that's a claim that was made
which was very very wrong
um
oh I guess uh Sandy Smith went Guilfoyle
it is time to see
the sand border
okay
my name is Sandy Smith and I'm your
American Patriot and together we are
gonna get our country back on the right
track I need your help I need your vote
and I need you to sign up to help go to
Sandy smithmc.com and together we're
gonna win this
it is time okay good for her
um let's see
I'm gonna skip the Herschel Walker stuff
for now
what is Rosh Hashanah
hmm
[Music]
that's why in Idaho it's it's going to
be a shift your shout is going to shift
America into winning elections that they
thought they could steal you're not
hearing me
they're trying to you know um
I I'm Jewish I would not listen to this
guy about Rosh Hashanah okay let's let's
not do that let's skip that because I
don't even want to delve into that that
just seems very very bad very bad
uh let's see what else we have from the
Trump rally here
um
let's see Newt Gingrich was asked about
the j6 committee what do you think about
the January system
you have no thoughts about the
permitting itself three issues
three or four times I don't I don't talk
about it they don't seem to try them I
think you have a learning disability
okay interesting interesting thing to
say during a uh
during an event all right I think we're
going to get away from this stuff it's
oh just one other really funny thing
um
J.R Majewski who was recently caught
lying about his military service is now
saying there's no record of it because
it's classified in fact the orders and
the military records that I've been able
to
obtained from my personal files shows
that all of my deployments are listed as
classified very very secret stuff guys
this was a strategic
and strategically placed excuse me
to crush me and defame me with a fake
hit piece
he can't give us the records because
they're classified enemies of the truth
did not bother to publish that
the Air Force has explicitly stated
there is no way for us to verify whether
or not
J.R Majewski served in Afghanistan
during his deployment time frame and
Qatar in fact the order
does anybody like is is it possible that
that's true I mean just I don't you know
you guys tell me it's all being
investigated but you guys tell me is
that is that all you know possible
it just doesn't ring true to me it
doesn't ring true to me yeah I smell BS
I smell BS but listen we'll eventually I
think the truth will come out I think
eventually the truth will come out all
right let me say thank you to a few more
people freak igtee DJ White Rabbit
McKinley and lilika as well as my STX
have just grabbed twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 19. I also
want to say thank you to Courtney beckon
Courtney signing up at joinpakman.com
and Lisa Rader gifting a subscription at
joinpakman.com appreciate that very much
couple of different um oh hold on a
second guys you know what
I am going to ban this really annoying
cool kid just it's just annoying me just
go away okay we don't just watch
somewhere else I don't care
um okay couple other updates number one
we are truly now in the home stretch on
1.5
million YouTube subscribers okay this is
really really important stuff as many of
you may or may not know we not that long
ago hit the Milestone of a million
subscribers and we are now pushing
towards 1.5 million this is where we
stand right now
and I am looking very much forward to a
day hopefully in the near future where I
can tell you ladies and gentlemen we got
them okay that is that is my hope and
slowly but surely those numbers are
trickling up and I think we're going to
do it sooner than later I think it's
going to be absolutely fantastic just an
absolutely fantastic thing
um so that's going on
secondly the finance channel is live
there are now four video clips on it
this is by popular demand this is
completely by popular demand people said
David you know your background is
actually in per in financial planning
what about the finance Channel and we
have done it ladies and gentlemen we
have done it the channel has been
launched we are currently uh just we're
three days in and at 5600 subscribers
and climbing so uh youtube.com Pac-Man
Finance if you want to skip the politics
this is really the place to do it where
we are doing just personal finance
that's what it is I don't give advice
per se uh it's really just context
context and a framework on a lot of
different Financial questions
it's going really well so far okay so
pack five pack Finn I don't know we're
still kind of trying to figure out what
it is that we're going to call it but
all really really exciting stuff and
glad to have people uh being a part of
it and a little bump there so exciting
exciting stuff as we stand by here for
Donald Trump at the Save America rally
just moments away moments away which is
an incredible incredible thing all right
let's get to some super chats here uh
David could Trump be going for a
diminished responsibility response his
recent comment on declassification Via
telepathy suggests early stages
I just tripped on a cable of mental
illness yeah I honestly have no idea
what Trump meant by that and also when
Trump said he thinks that the FBI was
actually looking for Hillary's emails at
Mar-A-Lago it doesn't suggest someone
who is cognitively stable that's for
damn sure
I don't know what to make for of it
starlink will soon bathe Iran in waves
of unrestricted internet Freedom per
secretary blinken and Elon Musk
interesting Joe we will look into that
Sir with tears in my eyes I ask couldn't
we build a special one-man prison for a
convicted ex-president does he have to
get off scot-free listen if Trump were
to be convicted and be uh sentenced to
prison time he would almost certainly
serve it at home in with home
confinement that's that's the bottom
line
as an Air Force veteran in Intel we
don't serve in Afghanistan we support
units from Qatar he's not telling the
truth our deployments are not classified
interesting Haley very very interesting
Lewis says there could be a record of
his deployment but not what he did if it
was classified that was the usual Stolen
Valor defense BS I didn't know that
that's in that's good to know yeah see
this is why it's so good to have people
in the audience who are uh vets so that
they can explain this stuff to me
that's very very important and it seems
like a number of vets in the audience
agree on that
thank you to Solis Balo for signing up
at joinpakman.com you were new member
number 22 today
um also thanks very much to Beth Graham
whoa my Windows updates popped up Beth
Graham who is new member number 23 today
as we stand by for Donald Trump let's
listen to a little bit of what's
Happening Here I will say this Kamala
Harris being in charge of the Border has
made still can't pronounce it huh one
one trip to El Paso which is hardly
where the crisis is going on and you
want to guess how many visits President
Biden has made to the Border are you
ready for this zero that's zero as a
senator zero as a vice president and
zero ever he has never been to our U.S
Mexico border in Mexico the immigration
crisis that we have right now he's never
addressed the immigration crisis does
anybody know what the crisis is like in
other words how is it different than
what was going on under Trump what's the
crisis you know coming in so
got to think about it how serious are
they with fixing the immigration problem
it's about fixing
this right side broadcasting anchor is
also one of Donald Trump's lawyers and
it's I don't know that it's like a
conflict per se I mean it's just
right-wing nuttery on in all jobs but
um
it just it's weird I guess they're
they're saying that yeah these are the
results they want this is what they want
they're aiming for so there's no they're
not they're not even at least in this
regard they're not even being dishonest
about it Kara jean-pierrez when she says
oh there's no problem at the border or
oh we're trying to fix it but
Republicans are in the way she is
dishonest I also think she has no idea
what she's talking about if she's not in
the know let me talk go ahead well but
the fact that my York is saying we're
getting the results we're after that's
what they're getting they're not all
right so total and complete delusion now
on over on Newsmax we have Peter Navarro
as we await Trump let's listen to that
petroleum sector
yeah they've sabotaged so many so many
ways that this country was functioning
uh in in recent years have been
sabotaged all for a political agenda
that I just I cannot figure out I cannot
figure out who thinks that this country
is moving in any kind of a good
direction new study from the Heritage
Foundation found the average American
lost forty two hundred dollars in annual
income since Biden took office it's
completely wiped out the wage gains
which are rather impressive because of
the Trump Administration wage gains that
I I think Obama said would be impossible
to see today Biden said this with a
straight face take a look remember
seeing all those food line people in
nice looking automobiles waiting for an
hour hour and a half just to have a
bucket of a box of food put in their
trunk in the United States of America in
the United States of America that was
happening
foreign
that's just amazing to me I spin job
like that Peter blaming Trump for the
repercussions of coveted lockdowns that
he's so harshly fought against yes yeah
look um this this election Rob in
November we've got to take back Trump's
America Trump's America was one of
prosperity uh price totally delusional
completely delusional super chat's
coming in Ace says you know the
cognitive test Trump talks so much about
they give you that test after a stroke
yeah I know I know it's uh he thinks
it's like an IQ test it's bizarre
enigmatic engineer says obviously Biden
needs to send the entire military to the
Border David of course
of course he does of course he does
um it's uh the it these people are
delusional these people are completely
and totally delusional I want to say
thanks to Olay shell for gifting a
subscription at joinpakman.com new
member number 24 today also thank you to
Green Man now subscribed 30 months on
Twitch
re-subscribes with the message I passed
the cognitive test absolutely Green Man
couldn't have said it better myself and
also big thank you to Juan for the
membership at joinpakman.com gifted
let's listen to a couple other
voicemails okay folks please voicemails
hi David this is Steven calling in with
Trump recently saying that he wants the
death penalty for human traffickers yes
many have argued that he basically just
called for Ron DeSantis and Greg Abbott
to be put to death yes isn't it worth
pointing out that Trump also claims that
Ron stole his idea in that name mean
that if Trump was to have this law go
through he not only likely end up having
his take but he'd be forced to eat it
too
thank you that part I don't know that I
understand
but uh
a very interesting voicemail nonetheless
um which which I like
David please
um
explain to me where do you think the
David Pacman show would be in 2022
had there never been a trump
Administration I think there would be no
David pakman show in 2022 were it not
for Trump in fact I I owe my life to
Trump
uh yeah I think I would have I would
have nothing there would be nothing
nothing nothing nothing
um let's see what else we've got here
I was just wondering what the the
special Master would do if he finds a
financial documents required by Leticia
James
um uh I don't think that's gonna happen
oh listen to this this is wild General
prosecution you're supposed to negotiate
we're talking about documents we're
talking about documents that actually
are being watched over to a certain
extent and I would say to a large extent
by the Secret Service
Trump's documents were stored in his
home guarded by Secret Service
and locked away now I'm not a lawyer and
I'm definitely not a librarian so I
can't tell you every little step a
president is technically supposed to
take to move around his paperwork
technically what I can tell you is what
past presidents did and how they were
treated let's start with President
George H.W bush his presidential records
ended up in a strip mall
store that used to house a bowling alley
and a Chinese restaurant
where bowling shoes co-mingled with top
secret documents I don't know
I'm not a national security expert but
if your storage room shares a parking
lot with the Chili's and a JCPenney is
that secure who's to say pretty good
comedy huh guys they'll say anything it
seems it's uh it it's really really wild
stuff uh Wesley says telepathic
declassification yeah many in the
audience finding it funny that Trump
said during that interview he could
think about a declassification and the
document becomes Declassified any
thoughts on the gates report of no
criminal charges no I haven't seen any
of that Matt Gates criminal charges
I don't know what happened
um
prosecutors recommend against charging
oh wow that's interesting yeah I'll read
it for Monday I'll cover that on the
Monday show I this is the first time
hearing of it very interesting like
we've been saying all along it may be
going nowhere
uh
uh yeah I'll look into that more in
follow up Monday
kahali and Tesla driving vegan just got
subscriptions via twitch Prime which I
very much appreciate and it's so great
to be uh welcoming you here let's see
what else we have as far as uh
voicemails go uh David Kirkman
um your confidence
um for the Democrat Party retaining the
Senate is overestimated
uh bench Arrow of lifting these polls
and um
so these poles don't look good for the
Democrats it does not look good
I predict
all right I don't even care what Troy
York predicts it's just it's irrelevant
his predictions are uh his predictions
are completely completely irrelevant
for commenting even before
segment but pillow hires dershowitz oh
my god look we know pillow is paying
because durso would not do this if he
wasn't getting paid you know that right
now if if dershowitz believes in the
issues so much why didn't he work for
Trump
why didn't this great lawyer who's
supported Trump so much why didn't he
work for Trump oh yeah because he wants
to get paid Shalom brother all right
well thank you very much Eggman a very
very important interview I uh uh that uh
we we played the other day of dershow
it's explaining explaining what's going
on
I'm just noticing
in my notice like people really really
in like features of like Jewish people
oh God
Whitney is really obsessed with Judaism
lately and just days before Rosh
Hashanah uh and a little weak plus
before Yom Kippur it's sad it's very
very sad I have to tell you that the
obsession is is really not so good
um oh where are we on 1.5 million will
we make it by mid-october yeah I already
we we talked about that already this is
where we are in the fight for 1.5
million subscribers we are at 1.49286
eight nine zero one point four eight
nine three
eight nine seven
wow something's happening here
um yeah I I my hope my goal was to make
it to 1.5
before uh election day
oh are people angry about this oh it
looks like people they're triggered
people are triggered that we're actually
going to get to 1.5 million subscribers
wow YouTube there's so many people I
stepped away from the YouTube chat for a
moment
what what do you care if I get to one
point why are you so angry
like who cares we might get to 1.5
million how does it affect your life
just go watch some right winger if you
don't like me
no we don't we're not going to ban them
for that we'll ban them if they say
something anti-semitic but
what is wrong with these people who who
cares it's it's guys it's subscribers on
YouTube it's not a big deal okay so I
don't know what the estimate is I don't
know what the estimate is but I I think
it should be plausible to make it by uh
by by November okay
so that's what's going on all right and
then Pacman Finance is uh we're still
working on our first uh first six
thousand subscribers there so
everything's everything's totally cool
with that super chat's coming in um
David I just logged into your Twitch
channel to participate in the chat and I
received an ads for Carl Juniors do you
think they're better than Hardee's I
have no idea I've never been to a
Hardee's and it's been 20 years since
I've been to a Carl's Jr so I'm the
wrong person to ask
Levi says uh Dems need to do something
regarding the Supreme Court Trump could
appeal classification of Mar-A-Lago
documents and executive privilege for
January 6 Witnesses what stops an
illegitimate Court from shutting
everything down nothing
this I mean we've been dealing with the
problem of the Supreme Court for a long
time
that there's no you know
where we've been screaming about it for
a very very long time
thank you to SLP lawyer SLP lawyer is
new member number 29 today on Twitch
very much appreciate that also want to
say thanks to Brandon Jordan who is new
member number 30 today let's go Brandon
I appreciate that uh the support there
let me mention and I will mention this
once and only once I would love for you
to support the work we do we have 14
streams scheduled between now and
election day at least because of all the
different debates and different things
okay grab a membership on my website we
have a coupon code the code is indict
you can do monthly or yearly I say do
yearly because you save more you type in
the coupon code indite and then
incredible things happen as you can see
here now if you want an even better
coupon code you can use the coupon code
Obama Obama and you'll see that it's
even crazier I won't even say this out
loud
because it's it's humiliating and you
can also do it on the monthly and look
at this folks I mean it's just
unbelievable this genuinely does support
the work we do we've got
um a custom commercial free audio and
video stream for people who sign up we
do the uh the daily bonus show which is
the best and we also do members only
town halls and all sorts of different
things so I would love for you to sign
up on my website we are expecting Trump
momentarily it's going to be an absolute
complete total mess that I can't even
imagine I can't even imagine what is
upcoming here but it's going to be
Bonkers I've not seen them yet all right
we're still we're still standing by
there
um okay other super chats coming in
Tom sends a Super Chat Jim sends one
Ally says sir what do you think our
chances are of seeing the Trump clan in
handcuffs very low
very very low
if Trump truly Declassified everything
couldn't the public make a foia requests
to get the documents
I don't know the answer to that I don't
know the answer that we should ask a
lawyer about that whoa I just hit my
head on the mic grave born just gifted
50 subscriptions on YouTube putting us
at 80. wow
that is an incredible number
um David are solid gold toilets that
flush appropriate for a conservative
portfolio
uh yes serious note how do you feel
about buying gold bullion I am not big
on on physical gold it's uh inconvenient
to store it can get stolen and to be
totally honest I think in that bug out
scenario where you need physical gold
I think we're screwed anyway that's my
view but everybody has their you know
their own opinion zelgeth gifts five and
Kevin Taylor gifts five that puts us at
90. over on Twitch I want to say thank
you to Blueberry babe for gifting one
and putting us at 91 and thanks to Stage
presence for gifting a membership on my
website putting us at 92.
things happening very very strongly here
and I think very soon Trump is going to
be speaking it seems obvious that that's
the case I do think he will be unhinged
I do think that he will be dangerous I
think both are almost certain to be
realities during today's speech yeah
uh do I have any other voicemails yeah
let's see I've got one more here
hey David it's Tommy if Trump can just
think about documents and declassify
them yeah
can't Biden just reclassify them oh yeah
that's exactly what what we just said
It's The End guys the entire thing is
absurd I mean telepathic
declassification it's it's ridiculous
thanks to Ace for gifting five more wow
my Windows updates are really persistent
today putting us at 97.
um thanks to Lacon the Great
for uh signing up via twitch and S Perez
gifting
69 subscriptions putting us at
267. guys let's go for 200. let's do it
um just a few minutes here until Trump
speaks and I'll try to thank as many
people as possible thanks to Javier for
getting a new membership on my website
Douglas Ness Daniella honku Gabby Bryant
and a gift from Desiree Delong that puts
us at 172. really appreciate that folks
the website is under pressure the
website is under pressure thanks to just
swaggy and Zuzu Pebbles who gifted five
that puts us at 178. a lot of a lot a
lot of a lot of anti-Semitism in the uh
chat today and I know that our
moderators have banned dozens of people
already which is sad to me it really is
sad
uh 100 Savages says hi David dark
Pac-Man looking good man what's your
position on honeycrisp apples Honeycrisp
is fine but it doesn't hold a candle to
Granny Smith Granny Smith My One True
Love
when it comes to Apples still the best
still the best thanks to Marcus Paris
para christenko for signing up on my
website and davidputterman putting us at
180.
thanks to Anthony bolios and Harold
Westley for signing up on my website wow
I'm gonna just close that out that's
crazy the Windows updates really want me
to restart and I don't want to do it
right now
I don't want to do it right now because
we're in the middle of a stream and I
would lose my connection to all of you
if we were to do that
last few moments here we have uh
oh people are commenting about what's
going on with my microphone
hey Dave it's Tommy so that's twice now
within a week that you've had physical
altercations with your microphone yeah
I'm afraid pillow's gonna have no choice
but to file a class action lawsuit
against it
I really have been struggling with the
microphone lately it's been it's been a
fight uh let's see what's happening and
all that as engaged as he has been with
everything he's doing with the rallies
this is just one more step for him to be
even more engaged to try to help America
First candidates save America yeah it's
funny they act like Trump actually helps
the people he rallies for but he barely
talks about them
like he'll call them up for a minute and
if they don't just
um
basically praise Trump
he looks visibly bored and kind of wants
them wants them off the stage oh look at
this yeah people just pointed this out
okay so this is this is super
interesting so as you can see here we
are fighting our way to 1.5 million
subscriptions on um on YouTube you can
actually get a projection on socialblade
of when we are expected to hit certain
milestones and I said I'd like to hit it
by election day right now socialblade
says if we can just keep going the way
we're going we will hit 1.5 million on
November 1st so that would achieve the
goal of getting there before
um election day but obviously we can
change that trajectory we have control
over this trajectory but that's where we
are right now and uh the numbers
beautifully inching up I know it's I
feel like we are going to get locked up
we're gonna get locked up I know we are
but the numbers are swelling like
Trump's head
um and ego I guess I should say
and pants by the way I don't know how
many of you saw that recent thing
um yeah so so that's great um November
1st is the current estimate and I think
we could potentially even do it sooner
okay so that's that's where we are right
now
um more Super chats coming in
let's see where else we are here
uh Trump is playing Suspicious Minds by
Elvis irony is dead the songs Trump
plays most of the artists would be
horrified that or that Trump is using
their music
I heard Jimmy from Philly is a paid
crisis actor is that true David I
couldn't tell you
I couldn't tell you
um and yes 50 gifted subscriptions there
from graveborn which I really appreciate
folks the website
is under extremely heavy technical load
here I don't know if it's going to be
able to stay up because of the number of
people signing up Shelly Gerst is a new
member Cindy cantagallo has just signed
up Jeffrey wittig and Zach Parker thanks
to Paul Edwards and Marcus Webster
welcome to Eric Chenoweth and Jenny
bonwich that is eight putting us at 190
within Striking Distance of this next
goal of 200 which we may be able to do
before Trump speaks any moment welcome
to bionic bill over on Twitch really
appreciate that
a couple other voicemails here's one
from Juan
hey David uh
I've tried very hard to uh
assimilate
the content uh considering
the cobwebs in my mind and my brain
and a series of other things
um
let's put a little bit perturbed
uh sad I guess you could say
that I still haven't been unbanned for
YouTube oh no you we did unban you we
recently unbanned you actually I uh made
sure of it there was a glitch on YouTube
that wouldn't allow us to unban anybody
it's kind of funny because of it
um we we literally it's like every band
on YouTube has been a permaband because
there was a glitch affecting our entire
Channel we couldn't unban anyone on
YouTube it's been fixed and you've now
been unbanned so it's all it's all set
all right my friend thanks to Robert E
630 for gifting 10 subscriptions thanks
to Jen here and an anonymous gifter each
gifting one more that's 12. and that
puts us at 203 folks let's go for 250.
let's do it thanks to Audrey Howard as
well as Eric Gorey for signing up on my
website putting us at 205.
super chats coming in David sometimes
your political commentary is explained
through knowledge principles in
psychology and sociology would you ever
do a show with Dr Todd Grand I don't
know who that is so I can't commit to
that offhand but I'm glad to investigate
and see what's up has anybody heard of
Dr Todd Grand let's see who that is Dr
Todd
and
licensed professional counselor
has a YouTube channel with over a
million subscribers
seems interesting I would I would look
at doing something with Dr Todd Grant
sure
uh
in fact I'll make a note right now
to have our team reach out on Monday
Dr Todd Grand
that seems interesting I appreciate the
suggestion thank you always glad to get
suggestions from people
very exciting Chris Sutton says truth
truth truth well if you're hoping for
truth I don't think you're going to get
a lot of it tonight let's see what
they're chatting about here as we are
moments away from Donald Trump's impact
on the state North Carolina was thriving
under President Trump and now under Joe
Biden they're they're hurting it looks
like what's going on who's coming out
okay we've got Lieutenant Mark Robinson
yeah the lieutenant governor here in
North Carolina who I think he got the
biggest cheers and the the biggest
Ovation I really enjoyed his speech
today as well it was just it was
touching yeah and I've heard him speak a
number of times but yeah super super
exciting okay
this is a fair question what am I
willing to do to celebrate when we hit
the 1.5 million as I've said before I'm
willing to consider anything no one's
really presented good ideas it's like
for some reason it always comes up oh
1.493 beautiful
someone always suggests would I dye my
hair
I mean I guess you know the the thing
about it is we're gonna get to the 1.5
eventually
it's a more interesting question of like
what would I do if we made it by October
1st right because that's a stretch goal
what would I do if we did If We Made It
by October 1st
that's more interesting to me because it
looks like it's going to take us till
November
um
and people you know it's like I'm not
getting a face tattoo guys I'm not
getting a face tattoo I get a fake one I
guess
um
yeah I don't know it's like I don't know
why hair stuff is like the most
interesting thing I'm not piercing a
nipple no
would I dye my hair orange yeah maybe I
mean like is that even interesting would
it be interesting for me to dye my hair
orange if we make it by October 1st that
doesn't seem that interesting
I don't know
uh it's more like there's a lack of
reasonable ideas I guess would I get a
spray tan to look like Trump that could
be damn funny if we make it by October
1st would I get a spray tan Orange
I might will be willing to do that like
is that even is that even interesting
people think that would be interesting
yeah maybe I would consider get I'd get
a spray tan like this guy I guess
um I would consider I mean it's if it's
funny I don't know if it's I don't want
to do something that people won't find
funny so I'm willing I'm willing to look
at that Olivia drabney just signed up on
my website and his new member number 206
today other super chats coming in leave
your sub bar up let people get pissed oh
why do people get mad when I uh
wait where was that people get mad when
I show this just because it's on the
screen that seems like a weird thing to
get mad about
look at that look at it trickle up it's
a beautiful thing
this is happening in real time guys
people are getting mad okay well we'll
take it off then I don't know
s press with an incredible oh now oh wow
you know s Perez is not just only an
incredibly appreciated contributor to
the show between beautiful super chats s
Prez some people don't know this has
gifted over
1500 subscriptions on Twitch Espress
could be a good producer as well
suggesting that I actually fast on Yom
Kippur if I get to 1.5 million by Yom
Kippur okay let's see
Yom Kippur date 2022
October 4.
I think I would be willing to do that
that actually sounds interesting if we
got to one I never fast on Yom Kippur I
should hire s Prez to do some production
because that's actually pretty good
if we get to the 1.5 million
by Yom Kippur which is October 4th
I will actually fast which I have never
done on Yom Kippur before that sounds
good that sounds it's one of people
asking what is Yom Kippur it's the it's
a Jewish High holiday we have New Year's
coming up Sunday Monday and then a week
after that that sounds interesting
yeah I mean it's not like I really wanna
I think what's good about it is it's
it's related to me like me randomly
getting a spray tan has no relevance to
me
and also
um
it's like so like I don't want to do it
so I think that that's a really
interesting idea I think that's a really
interesting idea I I will commit to that
I will fast on Yom Kippur
if we get to 1.5 million on YouTube by
October 4th now here's the rule guys it
has to be October 4th at midnight
at midnight I need a plan for that
because it can't be that if we get to it
by 2PM on October 4th then it's so I've
I've already missed the fast okay so
that means at the end of October 3rd
midnight October 4th if we're at 1.5 I
will fast I will do my Yom Kippur fast
and then we will see interestingly
enough nobody really seems to care about
it like the subscriptions have not
accelerated at all on that basis it
seems nobody else really cares about it
which is oh would I would I be willing
to order and sleep with a my pillow
I would consider that I would consider
that as well
if we get it by
hold on a second
if we get it by
um October 1st will I buy a my pillow I
guess I mean that that doesn't seem
quite as funny okay other super chats
David sir two almost equally scary
scenarios I can see from outside the U.S
one Trump finally goes down and sets his
cult on the U.S to take revenge oh yeah
there will if Trump gets indicted there
will be violence by his supporters it is
not even a question guys
not even a question
two he gets off again runs and wins and
democracy is dead yeah that's a scary
scenario too
Espress with another hundred dollar
Super Chat I'll have my people call your
people perfect
let's do it
when you hit 1.5 million I'd love to see
you debate a Maga Republican on a live
stream well listen
every time I take live calls Mega
Republicans are welcome to call in
and also I interview Maga Republican
candidates all the time and I disagree
with them all the time do an entire show
pretending to be Alex Jones if I get
there by October 1st I don't think my
voice could take it here is just 20
seconds of me doing an Alex Jones
impression I would need like a month off
to recover my voice globalished
internationalist trotskyite socialist
unlike Obama Trudeau macron and the rest
of these Zio Bishop
yeah no I can't I can't do that that I
think I would uh it would just be really
really really really bad for my voice
thanks to Rack Attack and iconic song
for the two twitch Prime subscriptions
look at how close we are at 208 out of
250. also thanks to David Levin for
gifting a membership on my website if
you're just joining us Donald Trump is
already half an hour late meaning he's
probably coming out any second I have
one favor and one favor only to ask you
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender transgender no no
that's that's not the favor that's
stupid and extraordinarily transphobic
that's not that's not the favor the
favor is I would love it if you went to
my website and just got a membership
that's it I'll announce your name and
pronounce it as accurately as I can
and we have a coupon code indict which
saves you like sixty percent okay
um
would I go skydiving when we get to 1.5
million no you know what skydiving is
far more dangerous than people might
assume and I want to live it's just I
just that's just a no I'm not going
skydiving at 1.5 million not happening
not happening
just sorry guys sorry I'm not gonna do
it
uh okay let's see what else we have here
break your fast at a Hardee's drive
through that I will not do that I will
not do
turbo has anyone asked you how it is
Trump's lawyer is interviewing people at
this rally no but I brought it up the
woman in the white hoodie is not only an
anchor on right side broadcasting she
also is one of Trump's lawyers now is
this a better you know this is not she's
also one of Trump's lawyers and it seems
wildly inappropriate that she even be
doing this job both jobs actually but uh
I don't know that technically there's
really any conflict of interest as weird
as it is
so she's allowed I guess
a black cat if I get to 1.5 million I
don't I don't know any black cats
if candidates or lawmakers can't get
money from corporations how do we
populate government thanks for the
unbanned how do we populate government
sure I understand that one Juan
not sure about that
if you make it to 1.5 million before the
end of the stream would you pull a
reuben and sell out and go work for
prageru sure guys exactly if we somehow
make it to 1.5 million YouTube
subscribers tonight I'll call Dennis
Prager and say Dennis
I'm ready to come over to the dark side
yeah
that's
not a great idea
wait a second
Dennis
I'm ready
the left left me
and so I'm ready to join you
because you were the only side that
still
sees the light
okay
um
all right did I see him on tyt last
night I did see a little bit of uh Anna
uh casparian interviewing uh Dennis
Prager I didn't find it super
interesting to be honest like the whole
first portion was Prager
coming up with stupid excuses for like
when when Anna pointed out tons of
leftists said they'd be glad to debate
you and he was like well not not the
really big media Outlets it's like dude
come on tons of leftists said they would
debate you and you constantly claim they
won't I want to say thank you to Joanne
Lighty as well as Stephen Phillips and
Sam Rosales all signing up on my website
joinpakman.com we have a goal of 250 new
website members and twitch subs today
and we're getting dangerously close I
want to say thank you
to Nancy Maul for gifting five on Twitch
putting us at 217. let's listen to what
they're chatting about here
I find that hard to believe yeah when
historically tripling the voter turnout
so there's some interesting uh
interesting investigations yeah one
place there there's also information
that a concerned voter group wrote to
the Wisconsin election commission
specifically about that District prior
to the election the complaint is dated
uh from July of 2020 before the midterm
election
saying you have about 4 600 illegal
voters on your voter roll for this none
of that is true unfortunately guys will
I do the one chip challenge when we get
to 1.5 million no and again remember
guys we we're gonna get there the
question is what would I do if we get
there sooner I'm not interested in super
spicy stuff
so no I'm not doing I'm not doing the
one chip challenge this uh Super Chat
asks will the USA use its Latin American
puppet Colombia to destabilize South
America and enforce green imperialism on
Brazil and Venezuela no
no I don't believe that that's going to
happen
how late is Trump uh 38 minutes late
what are they filling time talking about
we just we just listened to a little bit
I've been subscribed a long time wish I
could subscribe again well I appreciate
that I appreciate that
do a live remote from a trump rally at
1.5 million I don't know that that would
be safe
I don't know that would really be a safe
thing to do
thanks to Mildred Mitchell no I'm
kidding by the way I'm completely
kidding it just is not interesting to me
Mildred Mitchell just signed up on my
website Sam kinter and Justin Chaser are
the newest members on my website putting
us at 220 also thanks to kind AF who
just re-upped a twitch Prime
subscription both right side
broadcasting and Newsmax are covering
tonight's rally Donald Trump is now 38
minutes late and expected any moment any
moment any moment any moment and the
super chats are just pouring in guys do
you want me to keep going with super
chats or do you want to listen to a
voicemail or two
what do people want I mean we can do
both it's just more about the order
super chats or voicemail what do you
think
do it just check in on a voicemail
all right let's see
hey David if you manage to get to 1.5
million subscribers on the main channel
before November 1st I will get an Obama
neck tattoo Obama okay guys we have just
upped the ante this caller says he will
get Obama tattooed on his neck if we can
move up the date on which we hit 1.5
million
that now is starting to get pretty damn
interesting that act now I'm especially
since it doesn't involve me getting a
tattoo
I like that idea but you've got to then
take a picture of it and send it in oh
um I I that's that's super interesting
super super interesting
David
you get one
million subscribers by October 1st will
you return those panels to Sam Peter
by the way you are a loser whoa whoa
whoa whoa Pac-Man's a loser
um yeah I mean sure I'll give Sam the
panels back or something like that
I guess I don't know thanks to Thomas
Widow and Ian shaloner or shalinet
for the uh website subscriptions at
joinpakman.com very much appreciate that
let's see what other ideas people have
here I love the idea of a parody segment
of Alex Jones or another right-wing
idiot that could be fun love the show
yeah I mean but I don't know that that
is so exciting we tie it to the 1.5
million thoughts on Maga communism I've
never heard of that
has anyone heard has anyone even heard
of Maga communism I don't know what that
means
yeah it's uh not a term I'm familiar
with thanks to nurse Jilly nurse Jilly
oh uh here's an idea okay so here's
something I would be I would be willing
to do I don't know that this would even
really be funny but I would integrate it
um I would
I would be willing to get the voice
changer that our friend kit Boga uses
during his content
um and use it for something yeah I don't
know what I would do and like do the old
lady voice and stuff like that totally
glad to do that that's I mean just a
financial thing I just have to buy it
um but I would I would totally do that
could we do a poll with the top choices
for hitting 1.5 million by X date I
don't want to do that no because I don't
want to dissuade people from subscribing
in order to like get it right or for
lack of a better term so I don't want to
do that it's just it's going to be when
it is and we are beautifully
accelerating towards that as you can see
every moment that passes almost Folks
titillated by the prospect of me so far
what we've agreed to do is if we get to
the 1.5 million by Yom Kippur I will
Fast and I will I will live video blog
fasting sunrise to sunset on Yom Kippur
on like Tick Tock or something like that
okay
so that's what we've agreed on so far
1.5 million calls for a drum solo with
Obama mangos and Alex Jones impression
samples celebrate smash the drums would
love it that's a lot of production that
would be that's a lot to like set up
so I just don't know about that
not too sure about that
um
yeah I just I just don't really know
that we're doing that all right let's uh
let's take a quick listen Trump expected
any moment boy is another one that comes
out and and supports the president and
of course you know we see what late
night TV looks like I mean it's if it
wasn't for president Trump there's a lot
of stand-up comedians that would not
simply have any content because they
don't have the skills or the creative
team to come up with something fresh
they just make fun right there haven't
been 60 years of late night comedians
before Trump was President so they would
just have nothing to do that that makes
a lot of sense
um okay let's take a look here at some
other things happening in and around the
Trump rally if we have them
um
there might not be that much going on at
this rally to be honest
yeah we're not getting a lot of video in
from the rally
let's see
Trump rally
see what's going on there oh hold on
here we go oh now this is the good stuff
woman at the Trump rally says the race
was rigged but the Republicans that won
were legit oh this I have to hear I mean
I think it starts from the governor
I'll say it he's corrupt I don't think
he won there's no way when Trump
and all Republicans won the down line
that he won in 2020 and I I don't care
who knows that but but um you know it's
just I feel like the state
has a lot of corruption
oh you know what guys s Perez is making
a good point Yom Kippur is a full day
fast starting at Sunset the day before
Okay so
let me see sunset New York City October
4 2022. so if I'm doing oh god oh no
sunset on October 4th is 6 33 P.M
so basically that means if we're doing
the Yom Kippur fast for 1.5 million
subscribers
I need to know
oh wait no no no October 3rd I need to
know what's the sunset on October 3rd 6
35 okay that gives me two extra minutes
of eating
the fast would start at 6 35 Eastern
on Monday October 3rd so that's the
deadline
for the 1.5 to start the fast and if
that happens I guess I'll have a calzone
ready or something like that a beautiful
calzone with ricotta uh and everything 6
35 October 3rd that's that's brutal oh
wait it's Sunset the fourth to the fifth
oh I don't know what the hell is going
on okay so
October 4th 633 into the fifth man I
don't even I don't even know what days
this is all happening so it's the fourth
by 6 33 fine fine fine fine fine okay
let's go back to the clips that we were
doing here is a guy who explains why he
supports Trump
I'm going to tell you why I support
president Trump please
he is a problem solver
in fact
I'm amazed of his genius
this guy is shocked by how much of a
genius Trump is I I I'm gonna that is a
fascinating clip here's a guy who's
baffled by the fact that Biden hasn't
been impeached that Biden should be in
peace for what he's done
um with with wasn't what what he did
with Afghanistan for one
um just us leaving and not helping our
our troops that are still over there
today
it's just it it baffles my mind that a
sitting president can sleep at night
um knowing where he's done that button
pretty incisive guys hard to compete
with that I mean it's the guy's making a
lot of sense I have to tell you William
Merrill is the newest member on my
website number 225 thanks to shorty New
York jailhouse and narf harder for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
228 a couple other super chats Papi
suggests I visit Ukraine at 1.5 million
subscribers guys remember you have to
say what I would do and if we do it by
what date
if we do it by what date this really
really really is our last chance hey
kids once communist there is no coming
back to Freedom jeez
where who who's going communist I don't
even get that
1.5 million before Halloween interview
Whitney that's not as that's not a
stretch goal enough because we're we're
on track to hit it by November one so
one day early is not like that
impressive Denver I would gladly
interview Whitney but I think we've got
to make the goal a little bit more
interesting
um
here's a message about the mainstream
media from the Trump rally
propaganda it is lies that are being fed
to you by horrible people so really look
into it and look up what policies you
thrived under and the policies right now
that are hurting every single American I
honestly can't think of a single policy
right now that's hurting me that's
preventing me from thriving
I I just I really can't
um here's a guy who is conflicted
between Trump running again or DeSantis
running do you want to see him run again
in 24. I would love to but at the same
time I'd love to see DeSantis running as
well oh interesting all right
I think that the Sanders will be doing a
great job I mean look what he's on the
Florida uh he's been a great yeah you
guys just look at what DeSantis has done
to Florida I'm sorry in Florida for
Florida I mean great governor of Florida
um
I don't think I would love to see them
as running mates but I think that would
um cause conflict yeah that's an
understatement it would cause conflict
exactly right exactly right now they're
playing a Biden video
is this being played in the in the
stadium up against a Latina female
stand by just for Amy just stand by for
one second if you can hear me we've got
the crowd looking all everybody's
looking to the right and I believe it's
because the president's plane has
arrived looks like he's gonna be making
his way up to the stage here any second
now we're trying to get a handle on
where exactly he is in the crowd you
know he pops off the plane and uh oh I
see oh God look at this guys oh there he
is he's going to throw out some I'm
gonna throw out some what size hat is
that that is enormous oh it was a bunch
of hats I got it uh okay a few last
things here
1.5 million before the next Trump rally
you cover it live in person I don't
think we're going to make it by the next
Trump rally the next Trump rally is like
I think six days from now uh big big
thank you to Alyssa O'Connor also thanks
to Kyoko our friend Kyoko for gifting
two subscriptions that's three total
putting us at 231. folks can we get to
250 before Trump says a word
is that even potentially possible
from the majority report Jackson Hinkle
joins oan to talk about Maga communism
oh okay I'll check that out
uh Kyoko gifting one more puts us at 232
this is gonna be tight
this we may be able to make it before
Trump says a word
[Music]
[Music]
yeah all right we made it folks s Prez
just gifted 20 subscriptions 20
subscriptions beautiful putting Espress
now somewhere above 1500 which is a
crazy crazy number as Donald Trump is
about to speak
will I interview Trump at 1.5 million
sure I mean Trump's never going to agree
to be interviewed by me
that's just it's it's what it is you
know
that's not something he's going to do
okay let's um let me know in the chat is
Trump going to do the transgender line
today no teacher should ever be allowed
to teach transgender
will he say it today it's become a
staple a Mainstay of the rallies looks
like basically everybody says absolutely
he's going to say it
yeah I think he almost certainly will
Will trump say the following name during
today's speech
or Will trump name this gentleman
Okay let's listen Wilmington Halloween
oh technical problems are thrilled to be
back in the beautiful state of North
Carolina we won it twice and we want to
think that we want it easily with the
thousands and thousands of proud
hard-working American Patriots there are
a lot of people here that's a lot of
people
that's a big crowd Ted
great tit bud that's a big crowd you got
to be happy
seven weeks from now the people of North
Carolina are going to vote to fire the
radical left Democrats you're going to
send
the great Ted bud
to the U.S Senate you're going to elect
an incredible slate of true American
first Republicans up and down the ballot
and together we are going to end crazy
Nancy Pelosi's political career once
this election is a referendum on Biden
Pelosi Schumer the radical left democrat
congress that's destroying our country
that's brought our country really to the
brink of Ruin you know what's happening
you know it better and by the way did
you see the stock market today it wasn't
good
it was in good markets this is a classic
from from Trump when he was president on
bad stock market days he would say
nothing but brag on good days with Biden
as president he does the opposite it's
kind of worthless left office the price
of electricity is up 19 gasoline is up
two percent fuel is up up 91 milk is up
22 percent eggs are up only 46 eggs
that's interesting is up 24 percent
the 30-year mortgage rate has more than
doubled and real wages have declined 17
months in a row otherwise we're doing
quite well thank you very much
household well fell by a record 6.1
trillion dollars last quarter it's a
record never happened the stock market
has shed seven trillion dollars
in value this year think of that how are
your 401ks doing folks they must be
beautiful
must be beautiful Mark your Lieutenant
Governor how the 401ks Mark not too good
not too good over 5 million illegal
aliens have fluttered across our borders
and the number I think is a lot more
than that drug overdose deaths have
risen in North Carolina at a level that
nobody's ever seen before at least 26
and the murder rate is the highest in 25
years and probably the answer is 49
years this choice this November is very
simple if you want the decline and fall
of America then you should vote for the
crazy radical left Democrats and that's
what they are
[Applause]
if you want to stop the destruction of
our country and save the American dream
you must vote Republican
Joe Biden and the Democrat arsonists do
not care one bit about the pain and
suffering they're causing you your
family or our once great country
remember I was going to say it's going
to use an expression we have to keep our
country gay but but it's not I mean keep
the country gay that's that's new more
and we can name those reasons and we're
going to discuss them tonight now just
out of curiosity we have a one-hour
speech we have a two-hour speech we have
a three hours preach what do you want me
to do
oh no no no no no please don't threaten
me with that damn says three look at
Uncle Sam we love Uncle Sam I'll call
Sam
they're trying to ban you know Uncle Sam
he really wants to be Fidel Castro
three-hour speech dear God presenting
our country anymore they think it's
racist
I don't know Uncle Sam are you a racist
I don't think so
the only thing these deranged leftists
care about the only thing they talk
about is trying to destroy your favorite
President to me have you ever heard of
me and our Great Patriotic movement
that's true
there's never been a president that's
gone through the crap that I'm going
through left and right to left you feel
like a fighter left and right and then
you get up and you knock the hell out of
them
and I'm glad we put on the piece from
Jesse Waters you saw that just before
about the document hoax we have a Trump
plays clips now at rallies forget about
me with documents and then they go back
over the last five presidents you take a
look at that hoax
there's no better example of the left's
chilling obsession with targeting
political opponents and the baseless
abusive and depraved lawsuit against me
my family my company by the racist
Attorney General of New York State
Leticia peekaboo James
[Applause]
this raging Maniac campaigned for office
ranting and raving about her goal her
only goal is we got to get Donald Trump
we got to get him she knew nothing about
me I never heard of her
in fact I was watching it and I said boy
that woman's angry I don't think she
likes me too much
all without having any evidence she knew
nothing about me
before she had even begun her phony
investigation she went around boasting
her plan to weaponize her office against
me probably working with the federal
government of course
declaring I look forward to going into
office of Attorney General New York
state every single day ensuing him I'm
going to sue him
and then I'm gonna go home and I'm going
to be so happy because I sued him
she further screamed that his days are
numbers
and it's coming it's so many different
forms whether it's in Atlanta whether
it's from Washington DC whether it's
January 6 coming from many different
forms there's never been a period of
time like this and I thought actually
because Liz Cheney was so badly defeated
I thought that January 6th would go away
and I think it is going away actually
because that really was the sentiment of
a great group of people she got I think
was the largest defeat in the history of
Politics as a congressperson
and that was a referendum on what
they're doing in a fair country instead
of harassing me the Biden justice
department would be investigating
Leticia James for her appalling and
malicious abuse of power right we won't
even mention Hunter we're not going to
mention that because
he has nothing to do with that he just
said this too it's too long to talk
about it we'd be talking about
thankfully the latest polls show that
peekaboo James is losing to her
Republican Challenger this fall
it's very good too great great guy he's
a he's a real crime fighter
and we wish Michael a lot of luck
because he's representing a lot of
people that want to see New York change
it's a crime-ridden plays a big deal but
she doesn't just deserve to lose she
deserves to be removed from office
immediately disbarred and banished from
the legal profession forever
and that goes for others also
because these prosecutors these
Democrats are out of control they've
gone crazy yeah they're bunkers crazy
the Republicans don't fight that way and
I'm not saying they should I'm not
saying they shouldn't but you know what
it's a big difference on Leticia James's
watch New York has become a cesspool of
violent crime right homicides in New
York are up 52
robberies are up 38 and carjackings are
up uh listen to this one 286 percent
that's the new thing you get a new car
oh I love my car so much darling thank
you so much for buying and then a gun
goes through the window they say give me
that car
286 percent up rather than spending all
of her time going after me and my family
Ivanka think of it Ivanka
Ivanka is a very good person
Don Jr he's a good person Eric
Eric
these are good people yeah great people
this crazy radical leftist Nut Job James
should be going after the killers the
gangbangers drug dealers and MS-13
Savages who are ravaging the state of
New York but the radical Democrats don't
care about Prosecuting violent criminals
they only care about persecuting
Republicans or conservatives dear God we
got to remember this we got to remember
as we have seen in recent years our
opponents have shattered every principle
of Justice ransacked every institution
abused every Power in at least every
weapon of the deep state of bad news
media full-blown conspiracy theorist at
this point
look how many there are oh
wow
[Applause]
and the Silicon Valley census all to try
and stop us but it's not going to be
easy to stop us because there's many
many more of us than there are of them
and you know I don't even say
Republicans are conservatives I say you
know what I call us people with common
sense
since we don't want open borders we want
low taxes we want good education we want
military good strong military
we want all of the things that just
common sense it's really not
conservative Mark I don't think so it's
common sense
but no matter what these left-wing
tyrants throw at us no matter what the
sick Washington establishment does to us
we keep on going we keep on fighting and
we keep pushing for all the episodes
a very wealthy and successful man saw me
two days ago and uh I talked a little
bit I don't know if anyone saw Sean
Hannity last night but for the last two
millions it's shocking he's even
acknowledging that that interview exists
smart
and I told him that there was a man that
came up to me but this happens a lot a
lot and he came up and said you know
that tractor out there all that buzzing
means is that it's going backwards but
it'll stop it just stopped it's amazing
that tractor's a long way
I know a lot about tractors a man came
up to me very successful powerful man
and I said how you doing how have you
been he said very good but could I ask
you a question sure how do you take it
these fake prosecutors you went through
the impeachments you went through this
and you know our poll numbers today are
the strongest we've ever had that's a
lie was the guy crying also that's part
of the story right the guy was crying
when he asked him this and you know said
to him do I have a choice no these
people are crazy they're crazy
but we're on a mission to rescue the
America we love and restore the Republic
to Greatness and we will not fail we're
not going to fall you know there was a
time when Republicans would say
you never say the U.S is bad you never
you always say it's great but like we'll
make it better you know Republicans
would say it's too much to say the
country's not
perfect
and now he says it all the time this is
a totally different Republican party
pain think of it and it wasn't the
Russians that was spying it was the
Americans that was spying can you
imagine take Obama can you imagine if
one of us spied on his campaign would
they call for the death penalty or
something slightly worse than that
impeachment Oaks number one impeachment
hoax number two the unselect committee
on January 6th it's an unselect
committee I love that term I made it you
know they call it the select I said oh I
love the term unselect they are that's
Liz Cheney and her band of terrible
people how about Adam crying kid singer
he's another great Republican
[Applause]
eight are gone and the other ones will
be gone very soon
[Applause]
today that one Russell congratulations
Russell what a good job Russell where
the hell is Russell Russell I want a job
he bit his opponent so badly rice right
he beat him so badly that it was the
biggest single defeat for a congress
person in history lost by 26 points
it doesn't happen a sitting person you
know sometimes they get out they have
Scandal they have problems they get out
but nobody's ever lost by that much
until Liz Cheney who lost by 40 points
I'm sorry
Liz Cheney lost by 40 that's the biggest
defeat and then you turn on the fake
news and they say she's got a brilliant
future I wonder what her next move is
going to be I said no she lost my 40
points they're talking about her
brilliant future she's not got a
brilliant future
this week it has even been revealed by a
whistleblower that the FBI is taking
resources away from fighting crime and
using them for partisan political
investigations to falsely label Maga
make America great again Mega remember
what you know they say mega magamaga
they don't want to say what it means it
means make America great again really it
means making attorneys get attorneys
they want to call us domestic terrorists
you believe it I'm not a terrorist
but you know what there's great former
president denies being a terrorist how
many times has that happened never
forget
all of this torment persecution and
oppression is not happening because of
anything we've done wrong it's happening
because of everything our movement is
doing so right and so brilliantly
I mean we did win two elections right in
a row
quite a lot
did much better the second time that we
did the first Uncle Sam right got
minions and millions more votes the
corrupt political class in Washington
D.C hates us because we beat their rig
system we topple their entrenched power
structures and we expose their Lies We
reveal their failures and we laid bare
their betrayals we ripped up their
globalists those horrible globalist
trade deals as stinking rotten deals
that we got u.smca instead of NAFTA and
we made a deal with China That's So
greater with Japan that's so great with
South Korea all countries that were
ripping us off they don't like me too
much we stood up to their open borders
Insanity we confronted their sellout to
communist China we rejected their
ridiculous mandates those mandates were
bad we ended their endless Wars we were
the first one in many many decades we
didn't go into Wars we got out but we
were respected more than we were ever
respect affected as a nation we didn't
play games we got along with all of them
but they knew we were America First
America First all the way this November
the American people are going to show
this this is UN fact checkable because
it's all lies and delusion it's just all
the way down by voting in overwhelming
numbers to throw them the hell out of
office starting with
this disgusting human being
Leticia peekaboo James
we're going to drain the swamp we're
going to save our country
job why couldn't Trump do it in the four
years he had
Steve they're bad people
[Applause]
tell you before covet came in a gift
from China
commonly known as the China virus I
meant to be a covet what the hell is
covet it's called the China virus
you know Biden's afraid to say it they
don't want to say China versus China
virus but before it came in we had a
country that was doing so well China
black Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women men
young kids without a high school diploma
with a high school diploma first in your
class from MIT first in your class from
Wharton first in your class from Harvard
it didn't matter every single group had
I don't remember the third element and I
will tell you people were starting to
come together I will say that I was
getting calls
I was getting calls from people on the
left to put it mildly some of it would
say the radical left lunatics but I
don't want to say that because I want to
be respectful but they were calling to
get together and then we had the
horrible China virus float in came from
the Wuhan Labs remember when they looked
at me they said how do you know they
came or we think it came from Italy
remember they started to play poor Italy
uh it came from that never happened it
just Italy was a was an early hot spot
that's all China came from the labs they
either made a mistake you know they have
incompetent Trump now seems to have
completely bought into the lab leak
theory for which there's not actually
any evidence it's crazy but maybe it
wasn't but they're going to pay a big
price but it came from the labs but we
were doing better than ever before and
our country was actually coming together
and people that would not necessarily be
calling me were calling me to say
unbelievable job but that got destroyed
quickly and then we rebuilt it and we
handed over a stock market that was
higher than before think of it the virus
came in it was higher and today it's now
lower than it's been in years and it
seems to be heading south it's a shame
none of this should have happened it was
based on a lot of bad decisions but none
of this should have happened the war in
Ukraine should never have happened it
wouldn't have happened you could take
the five worst Presidents in American
history put them together and they would
not have done the damage Joe Biden has
done to our nation in less than two
short years it's true
two years ago when I was in office gas
gasoline for famous beautiful gasoline
was
1.87 cents a gallon
and it even hit one dollar and fifty
cents if you remember at one point there
is something particularly painful about
this
speech and you know they're using the
Strategic reserves which I topped out I
bought 75 million barrels of oil from
the oil companies when we were at an
all-time low I was so proud of it I said
what are they gonna what are these
fakers going to write a story that I
made a good deal because it started to
go after that but I topped it out first
time in 52 years that the reserves were
topped out and you know what happened
this guy four weeks ago said we're going
to start taking that because we want to
keep the gasoline low before the
election but after the election it's
going to go up like you've never seen
before
it's a shame I mean hey by the way a
small fuzzy Moss already got me the
audio glitch from today further screamed
that his days are numbers
[Applause]
[Music]
that's genius is now a beggar for energy
and Biden and the democrat congress have
just passed a massive anti-oil and gas
bill to put American Energy the hell out
of business can you believe this can you
believe it let's go buy an electric car
that travels for one hour and 49 minutes
and then you can spend four hours on
waiting for it to recharge if you folks
I recently drove from New York City to
Montreal
it's like 300 something miles
I stopped twice to charge 15 minutes
each time
while we fed the baby and did a diaper
change would have to do it anyway
it was totally fine the car has a 330
mile range it's fine everything's fine
though it's a larger
sike in my opinion it'll prove to be
pulverizing the middle class it's
happening to your middle class the green
New Deal they're spending trillions and
trillions on the green new deal it's
like taking money and throwing it out
the window and it's causing tremendous
inflation under the Trump Administration
we had the greatest economy in the
history of the world with no inflation
nobody's ever seen like it that's before
the virus came in then after we got it
back
we handed something off that was so good
and they blew it and they blew it at the
border because all they had to do is
leave it alone we had the strongest
border ever Biden and the democrat
congress created the worst inflation in
more than 50 years 9.1 percent and their
new so-called inflate I I know you think
you're being clever Azor who says David
your electric car is charged by what
kind of power plant it's charged by Sun
from collected by my solar panels
place with all these thousands of people
going as far as the eye can see thank
you very much
but it's a fake deal
and it's thrown the economy into a free
fall I built our military and rebuilt
our military including our nuclear
capability and the creation of space
force which everybody said no no no but
China and Russia were killing us in
space that we did first time in 78 years
since Air Force
they surrendered our strength and our
our real I mean our heart our heart and
I've totally lost his train of thought
glitch and in Afghanistan in my opinion
was the greatest humiliation that our
country has ever seen I don't believe
we've ever seen humiliation like that
Ted Bud you're not going to let that
happen I don't think we've ever had
humiliation like what happened in
Afghanistan and now we have a war
between Russia and Ukraine with
potentially hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people dying that would
never have happened if I was President
would have wouldn't have happened I
dealt with Putin I got along great with
Putin he wouldn't have done it but I
guarantee you he wouldn't have done it
and he didn't do it for four years there
was a soldiers built up on the border
and nothing he wouldn't have done it
didn't do it somebody said well he might
have done I said well he didn't do it
for four years and he didn't do it for
really five years during the campaign we
talked about he didn't do it for five
years all sound bites for the soundboard
can be sent to info davidpackman.com
the worst Border in the history of our
country
and you know what I believe it's maybe
the worst border anywhere in the world
and maybe in world history because it's
it's more it's even choppier than the
border between India and cash the
Kashmir region of India and and where
it's like look at it on a map and it's
completely out of control we have a
worse border than that guys like is
happening to the United States of
America
under my leadership we ended Catch and
Release we deported record numbers of
illegal alien gang members and we built
hundreds of miles of border wall despite
two and a half years of democrat
inspired lawsuits we want them all we
want every one of them
we completely finished our original plan
of the wall and then I said let's do
some more because we needed some other
areas and we got that almost finished
through this is a lie Trump's promise
was the entire border would have a wall
on it by the end of his first term he
didn't do it that's it get away they put
it away where Texas and Arizona can't
get to it in other words they want open
borders in short the election was rigged
and stolen and now our country is being
destroyed it's being destroyed what's
happened
I ran twice I won twice and did much
better the second time than I did the
first getting many millions more votes
thank you thank you for for leading my
lives
crowds deranged huh
[Music]
Mexico
[Music]
we've endorsed JPL J.D Mandel getting
millions and millions more votes in 2020
than we got in 2016. everybody says oh
you did so well in 2016 I said we did
much better in 2020. you know we got
12 million more votes I was told if we
get the same number of votes the same
number we can't lose we got 16. John
McLaughlin told him that I said what
happens if we get more well then you
definitely can't we got much more we got
more votes than any sitting president in
the history of our country by far far
more than Obama
far more than anything
but the good news is now we're leading
Biden by a lot and we're leading all of
these Republicans but it kind of makes
his loss that much more embarrassing you
know
and we may just have to do it again
right we may have to do it again
we may have to do it again
[Music]
but first we have to win a historic
victory for the Republican party this
November we have to swamp them you know
the best way we can stop them from
cheating because they're cheaters
they're dirty rotten cheaters the best
way we stop them from cheating is to
swamp them here's another new clip from
tonight's rally
people were starting to come
dear God so deliberately created at our
Southern border we're going to end that
we cannot continue to allow millions and
millions and I believe Ted it's 10
million people and probably more years
two and a half million it's not I
believe it's many times that number it's
numbers like nobody's ever seen before
there's never been a country ever abused
like this it's an invasion this week it
was reported that border patrol agents
have received an intelligence bulletin
stating that
Venezuelan dictator Maduro is opening up
all of his prisons and sending vicious
convicts and these are tough ones
charged with murder rape and other
heinous crimes straight across the
border
and into our wide open USA our beautiful
USA wait they're going they're going
across the Venezuelan U.S border it
sounds like he's skipping a few steps
there
[Music]
this is an invasion and the only thing
that surprised me about Venezuela is
what took them so long because other
countries all over the world are doing
it last year we were invaded
by 129
different countries think of it did you
guys know that 129 countries launched
invasions on the U.S Lester here they
opened their prisons I don't know what
took Venezuela so long but they've
opened their prisons and they let the
roughest toughest people that you'll
ever see you'll never see people like
this you don't know about people like
this in North Carolina you have tough
people too but they're people that like
obeying the laws they're people that
love their police and respect their
police and love their military these
people don't love their police and they
don't respect their beliefs
last month a sadistic illegal alien
criminal in Texas was sentenced after
committing a while this is the lurid
stories portion of the rally car
Jacksons in which
he called a carjacking a card Jackson
there any cases in four cases beat them
so badly that they died
he held guns to the head while they were
dying right here in North Carolina a
single day this year illegal aliens were
charged with two dozen sexual assaults
including one illegal alien Predator
charged with over a dozen sex crimes
including incest of a child a very young
child four years old and two counts of
crimes against nature unfortunately your
radical Democrat Governor Roy Cooper has
vetoed legislation
[Applause]
requiring authorities to turn over
important reminder everyone in the crowd
who's 18 is allowed to vote
Sienna they call them packs so they just
go and they start swinging you know I
know some of you people in these early
rows and I know some of them are tough
would anybody like to join ice and end
up in fist fights for the rest of your
life they end up they go into they call
them packs packs of very tough people
MS-13 people they like sometimes they
use knives to kill people because it's
much more punishing much more takes
longer they like that because they say
this they use knives to kill people
there's a lot of people are saying are
those stories Trump tells about these
violent acts even true that's a good
question I mean he lies all the time but
one of the really funny things is Trump
will sometimes talk about the conviction
of someone and he'll describe the crime
as many of you know it can take years
for the conviction to happen after the
crime I've looked up some of the crimes
he mentions the crime took place when he
was president but now that they've been
convicted while Trump while Biden is
President he blames it on Biden dude the
crime crime happened when you were
President office I said why they said
they won't accept him I said why won't
they because they don't want them back
because they sent them here let me tell
you they sent them here when they come
into the Caravans I think it was another
name I made up I made up plenty like
fake news like
some Republican name stupid we won't
mention because now they're all friends
of mine but I said to them why won't
they they won't do it they don't want
them I said that's all right do we pay
them money Honduras do we pay El
Salvador do we pay money to these yes
sir you do how much
approximately 700 million dollars
and so so we pay 750 million they won't
take them inform those countries
immediately that we're not paying any
money to them anymore we are going to
not pay any money because they won't
take back the convicts the prisoners and
some very bad people and terrorists that
they sent over to us so uh about 20
hours went by not 24 a little bit less
than 24. and I got a call from the
president
of Honduras
and I got a call from El Salvo that I
had a couple of other calls where they
came in
sure sure I understand that you're not
going to be sending any more money to my
wonderful country we were working so
hard on economic development projects
with the money that's not you know what
the economic development is their
pockets
I said that's right Mr President I won't
be sending any more money to them
because you won't take the people back
you know they used to line up airplanes
to head on their runways
what's that I did set up very strong
borders for our buses where we had buses
loaded up with gang members and bad
people Killers murderers rapists and
they wouldn't let them in
so I said no we're not going to give you
any money anymore unless you decide to
say we'd welcome to have MS-13 back we
look very much forward to having MS-13
come back
they said sure I'd like to uh it would
be our great honor to take them back
please be advised that uh our airports
are open our borders are open please
send them back
and you know the interesting thing I
still never paid him the money I figured
anybody have any idea what he's talking
about
but you know what Andrew me more than
anything Ted I have to tell you this so
we had done that and we were paying them
very little they were getting a lot but
they were getting 750 million dollars
that's a lot
at about three countries primarily three
countries and then I heard the new
Administration comes in then I heard
they were going to give them four
billion dollars four billion and I said
why because they want Economic
Development to take place because this
way people won't come in can you believe
the the stupidity of this so instead of
750 million they're now giving them
four billion dollars
[Music]
and you know what I didn't check this
but I'll bet they don't take the gang
members anymore also okay I'll bet you
that when Republicans take back Congress
we should immediately pass the Bill
introduced by Ted but allowing the
victims of sanctuary cities and states
to sue for damages when a loved one is
hurt or killed as a result of these
deadly people and deadly policies
break that North Carolina should be a
sanctuary for law-abiding Americans not
criminal aliens we're going to make
America great again and our first task
is to make America safe again all right
safe
just recently a young 18 year old man
from North Dakota I'm sure you read this
over the last two days named kaler
Ellingson a young man so handsome so
handsome beautiful
18 years old was targeted and killed run
down in Cold Blood with an SUV by a
radical left Maniac it was a radical
left
stupid person
simply because he was a Republican and
he was so proud of being a Republican
and this guy ran him down
and not one mainstream media network has
even mentioned this horrible crime think
of it now think of it the other way
think of it the other way supposing a
mega person ran down somebody on the
other side it'd be the biggest story
you've ever seen to disgrace you people
should be ashamed of yourself it's only
right-wing media in the back of the room
that no no actual media is covering this
Hearts go out to the parents and the
friends this
this is a young
young and I'm just telling you just so
handsome and so beautiful and so great
and he got run down by a radical left
nut job
here in North Carolina the radical
Democrats have Unleashed violent and
hardened criminals to prey on innocent
women and children you know that they're
releasing them all the time
four weeks ago a pregnant woman was
viciously shot in the head in a road
rage incident in Raleigh you know
Raleigh do we all know I'm trying to
remember the point of the lurid stories
is to point out that Democrats are bad
is that is that the point of these
stories really a young mother was
carjacked and brought daylight in a man
that I mean right by a Post Office right
by a mall an open parking lot in Durham
as her 10 month old son was sleeping in
the back seat killed
and in Charlotte a few weeks ago a 48
year old mother of four and grandmother
of three was ruthlessly gunned down and
killed in a robbery after she stopped at
an ATM machine to get some money to buy
groceries it's like a lot of these
crimes in red States
the criminals might be Republicans I
mean I just don't even get it because
because it's always tough to say what
I'm about to say but it's a great thing
a drug dealer will kill an average of
500 American citizens during his or her
life they'll destroy kill 500
not to mention the destruction of
millions and millions of families that
are so badly hurt
and I'm calling for the death penalty of
drug dealers and human traffickers which
will upon its passes reduce drug
distribution notice how these people
have been propagandized when Trump
started saying death penalty for drug
dealers people were kind of just like
yeah okay man whatever now that he's
known for calling for the death penalty
for drug dealers people actively cheer
like they love it they wait for the line
if you get out
[Applause]
of China and I got along very well with
President XI until the virus came in
then I said the hell with it but I got
along well
but I went to China 1.5 billion people I
said president do you have a drug
problem he looked at me like what kind
of a stupid question is that no no no no
drug problem I said you're quick
no no no no probably thought I was not
very sophisticated he said can you
believe the stupidity of a question like
that and I said so you have 1.5 billion
second to India catching up with India
actually try it but those are the two
biggest at about that number I said so
you have no why don't you have a drug
problem quick trial I said quick trial
let's see I think I know what that means
quick trial he said yes when somebody
drugs when somebody in our country sells
drugs
we take a trial it's a very quick trial
it goes very quickly and if they're
guilty that person is executed
immediately and we have no drug problems
and he said what happens is we had a
tremendous drug problem he said in China
tremendous in fact China was reduced to
a weak country a century ago because it
was all drugged out with the fields the
Opium and the different fields and
different kinds of drugs and I also told
them by the way
don't send any fentanyl to the United
States anymore don't do it we had it way
down and then as soon as I was out there
sending in record numbers they're
killing hundreds of thousands of people
in our country but I I learned from that
and then Singapore the same thing in
other countries and you know we have
blue ribbon committees
Blue Ribbon committees made up of
socialites and nice people but they
don't really understand what this is all
about remember this if you do the death
penalty for drug dealers you will cut
crime in this country I think by more
than 80 percent immediately if it's a
meaningful death penalty it'll take
place immediately it has to be a real
death penalty don't have a drug problem
are the places that have the death
penalty for drug dealers so I know it's
tough to say I sort of didn't want to
say it I've said it for the last couple
of weeks my people my great Geniuses
that do political stuff you know that we
all have to suffer through Mark we have
to listen to these people but by the way
how good a lieutenant governor do you
have
new topic
you've got our future the shiny object
just walked by
Mr and Mrs
wow
I'm very impressed oftentimes I do that
and people just don't care
they care about you too
but if you think about it and we would
cut crime in the country because a big
part of our crime is drug related crime
we have to get tough in our cities the
big thing we have to get so tough in the
cities you know it was up to the
governors to do then we had the
governors and they don't want to do a
Democrat all democrat-run cities and
states they're the ones that are letting
this happen and they're destroying our
great cities
and I have to as president if I had to
allow the governor to call in and I'd
call them what are you calling in like
in Minnesota Minneapolis what are you
calling in Governor uh we don't want the
guard they're burning down your city
Governor when are you calling in and I
just sent him in if we didn't send them
in you wouldn't have a Minneapolis right
now you wouldn't have had Seattle clean
remember they took out like 20 percent
of said they literally moved into
Seattle and took over a big piece and so
I said we're sending them in and as soon
as they heard we're sending them in they
scattered right otherwise they'd be
there today under a republican Congress
we should also pay emergency funding to
hire thousands and thousands more police
officers Nationwide and to put violent
criminals Behind Bars and to keep them
behind bars and wool so and so important
leave our police alone let them do their
job give them back their respect
they know what to do better than anybody
we have to allow them to do it we have
to allow our police to do it we just
have just put the handcuffs on our
police we've reversed it the first step
thank you very much I love you too very
much very very much thank you very much
thank you thank you very much the first
step to restoring Public Safety in North
Carolina is defeating the Democrats
radical these are radical radical people
you have where the hell do these people
come from this is not from North
Carolina
you don't have those values in North
Carolina and we have to elect Ted Bud to
the United States Senate this November
really strong endorsement Ted is running
against a weak on crime
sounds like Leticia weekend crime left
wing extremist named Sherry Beasley did
anybody ever hear of Sherry Beasley
she was a judge Jerry Beasley was she
was a Marxist radical who personally
stopped the death sentences of eight
death row inmates convicted of the most
hideous crimes including an animal who
brutally raped and murdered a
four-year-old girl a man who stabbed to
death a convenience store clerk and
sexually assaulted her while the knife
was still in her neck and a criminal who
grabbed the sheriff's duties gun grabbed
his gun well
he didn't think he had a problem with
this person he was trying to be nice and
while he was being nice and he executed
the sheriff at Point Blank Range she
stopped their death penalty and wants to
have them get out of prison this is such
an electrifying and inspirational speech
left in crime she formed a fundraising
partnership with the most militant to
fund the police Democrat in Congress a
person called Corey Bush did you ever
hear of her
and she'll support deadly Sanctuary
cities releasing dangerous criminal
aliens into your North Carolina
communities I have property in North
Carolina very proud of my property in
North Carolina Trump National on the
beautiful beautiful like largest
man-made Woman made lake in the world I
believe it's Great Lake Norman did
anybody ever hear of Lake Norman
in fact I'd like to go from here Ted and
go over to Lake Norman and do something
I love that property Sherry Beasley
doesn't know what you do at a lake but
he'd like to do something North Carolina
families in the middle of an absolutely
collapsing economy you know there's an
expression Trump was right about
everything and if you look we really I
was right about I was right about the
Border I was right about Ukraine I was
right about watch what Taiwan and I'm
I'm hope I'm not going to be right about
World War III because we have stupid
people dealing and you could end up
possibly end up better chance today than
ever you know Putin mentioned the n-word
you know what the n-word is it's no no
no it's the nuclear word he mentioned it
here yesterday the initially we're not
supposed to be mentioned you could end
up in World War III and this will be a
war like we've never had before it won't
even be close because we're being run by
stupid people
and worst of all Beasley has vowed to be
the 50th vote for abolishing the Senate
filibuster giving the radical left free
reign to ban voter ID Grant Mass amnesty
to illegal aliens pack the Supreme Court
they want to pack the court I don't
understand those justices uh they should
have shut them down a long time ago
they'll put on 22 24-23 that riled the
crowd when Trump said it's all about the
n-word the crowd was like oh now this is
kind of interesting in fact they'll have
so many chairs there you won't be able
to go into the Supreme Court anymore
and they want to do that and to pass
every other dangerous left-wing fantasy
that you can imagine if Sherry Beasley
gets in the squad will have total
control and they will drive America
right off the cliff it's almost there
now anyway what happened we just muted
something saying it I wanna I love it in
the country but it's so sad what's
happened to our country for two years
Ted Budd is a conservative America first
All-Star in Congress they love him the
congressman they all called could you do
us a favor could you endorse Ted bud I
said I hear he's good tell me about him
but a lot of people didn't know him his
area where he has been a congressman for
a long time they love him
but a lot of the people in the state but
once they got to know him he's leading
by a lot but don't I don't even want to
say that because you have to get out and
vote we don't want to have their leading
by a lap dead and everyone says oh he's
going to win and then they don't vote
that's happened before hasn't it to
people so we don't want to have so let's
assume he's down by one
but he will always defend your safety
your jobs and your North Carolina values
he loves the people of North Carolina
in fact I asked anyone ever hear of
Laura
Trump Laura
I said Laura why don't you run I think
we could get you I think you'd be I mean
you know she's so popular she grew up in
North Carolina she's incredible
married to my son and I have a good he's
I got good Sons I got good Sons I have
good daughters
but she's they've got a good daddy
that's true I would say
but she's married to Eric and you know I
said Laura why don't you run
she said because Ted bud is going to do
a fantastic job how about that I never
even told you about it yep
[Music]
but I think I would have
I would have hoarding you
I would have said Ted remember I told
you I was going to endorse you if you
don't mind I'm gonna take that sucker
back
no but she loves the state and she loves
you and she thinks you're going to do a
fantastic job so and I do too I know you
will right Ted will vote to stop the
radical Democrats inflation causing
spending binge and he will unlock
American Energy and bring prices way
down and what happens when the prices
come down to where they were Putin stops
the war he'll stop it anyway if I if I
decide to do this I guarantee he will
stop it very quickly is that very very
quickly
why not just have it stop now solid on
defending our borders he helped build
he fought for me in the war to fight
those Democrats like you wouldn't
believe
and he fights relentlessly to get
dangerous criminal aliens off your
streets
Ted is endorsed by the North Carolina
Troopers Association all of the police
are endorsing to not like they have a
choice I mean what's their choice a
radical left Democrat that wants to
defund the police she wants to defund
the police is she crazy how the hell do
these people get votes you know this is
by cheating that's how they get [ __ ]
and Ted is truly the candidate and is
said to be the candidate of a thing
called Law and Order you know that used
to be a term you're not supposed to say
right we'll say it all the time Ted and
as a gun store owner Ted will always
defend your second amendment so I'd like
to ask Ted Bud to come on up and say a
few words so remember if Ted Bud doesn't
mostly talk about Trump trump will start
looking bored very very quickly
foreign
[Music]
ate you have to talk about Trump why is
it all blue
I think I can speak for all of us here
who are glad to have Donald J Trump back
in North Carolina
sucking up
Mr President I can also say that we are
ready to stop the Biden Beasley agenda
and make America great again
we all know that the Biden Beasley
agenda makes our life worse but our plan
Mr President it did and it will again
make our life better
Trump's already bored comes to the
America First agenda president Trump
didn't back down
and when you endorsed me you said Ted
it's because you didn't back down so I
want to let you know that I'm not going
to back down either friends
all right
Mr President we just want to say thank
you we want to thank your whole family
as well now let's go win this for our
country
so he actually did a good job he mostly
talked about Trump and that's that's how
you're supposed to do it
great great gentleman he's going to
represent you long and hard long and
hard everybody needs to get out remember
you got to get out we don't have a
choice we're not going to have a country
left we're not going to have a country
left you got to get out you gotta swamp
them we're also he's gonna represent you
long and hard I don't even understand
that these are great people I've
endorsed them all Bo Heinz from North
Carolina's 13th congressional district
he's handsome and he was a very good
very strong football player usually I
don't like endorsing handsome people I
don't like it
but I have no choice great bro and I
hear you're doing fantastically it's
looking really good so good go out and
get them Sandy Smith from North
Carolina's first Congress
Congress
Sandy
and you have my total endorsement and
you get out and win that race and you
have a lot of congressmen
I'll tell you including Scott he called
me so many times I said just stop
calling me
but he loves Sandy so good luck okay
good luck
she's gonna be terrific thanks Andrew
yep and a man I'm really Miranda because
he beat
he
features
[Music]
[Applause]
Congressman rice
and Congressman I suffered a big big
loss that wasn't even it was an
unexciting evening because I guess the
polls closed at eight o'clock and at 801
they said Russell Frye has won the
election once took one minute it was a
Slaughter
South Carolina's seventh congressional
district big Trump district and it's an
honor to have you as my friend and you
are a professional and your staff I just
met backstage and I really want to
congratulate you on a great win I want
to get rid of all those impeaches we got
almost all of them out they're almost
all God thank you what a great job
you're going to be there a long time
thanks as well to I think one of the
hottest politicians in the United States
of America and has become a friend of
mine Lieutenant Governor Mark Robinson
wow
thank you Mark
super hot
right you're incredible incredible wife
thank you very much Mrs Robinson
Congressman David Rosier David Rose
I can't for pronunciation
but he's great and he's a warrior David
you've been a warrior you've been such
an incredible friend
thank you very much speaker
of the North Carolina House Tim Moore
Tim thank you very much
great job Tim
an apartment
would you like me to seduce you and we
did great little Mrs Robinson I never
had a problem
because you have in North Carolina GOP
chairman named Michael Whatley who's
fantastic where's Michael Michael thank
you Michael related to dentist Tim
Watley of course played by Brian
Cranston good I think so huh how's Mark
doing I think Mark's not going to have
too much problem whatever the hell hey
by the way whatever you're running for
what let me know I want to give you a
real early endorsement I don't know
but you have great people and you do a
fantastic job we appreciate it I think
very much thank you and the Ambassador
friend of mine is here highly respected
I gotta say this do you have any
football fansy I guess right
the craziest game
I ever saw
was the Jet game last week is that right
so there's like a minute and 37 seconds
left they're down by 13 points and
they're having a tough game
and they don't even have the ball
I think the chances of them winning was
1 100th of one percent and nobody would
take the bat and
[Music]
they got some kind of a fumble they
threw a long pass it was God they got
seven
and then they got an onside kick this
took place over like about a minute and
a quarter
and they received they got a uh an
onside kick and
they went for a touchdown and they won
the game because the other field goal
kicker Mr field goal somewhere during
the game crowd super engaged with this
story did they needed 14 points they got
14 points like in a minute and 12
seconds it was the craziest thing and I
called the coach because I think the
coach is like a great guy general
manager too coat I said coach
you're greater than Vince Lombardi and
he says Vince Lombardi never did that he
was never able to pull out a game like
that because I was the craziest thing
I've ever seen the game was done it was
over and the owner of
the Jets is here with his incredible
wife Woody Johnson and Suzanne Johnson
and they are so happy where the hell are
they
where are they
where are they
did that even happen as he described it
like I didn't see the game was that even
the way it happened better
he's better than anybody the greatest
coach more or less he's a great guy but
that was that was some game Woody I know
you expected to win
when you're down by 13 and you don't
have the ball and there's a
minute and a half left
but Woody Johnson's a great guy and his
wife is even better okay so I just
realized Woody Johnson what a name and
Trump's talking about long and hard it's
a bizarre speech tonight activates New
York captivates it this is also the home
state of
someone who I said before is very
special Lara we love you Lara I'm glad
you didn't run and I'm glad we didn't
need you we got Ted but Lara how good is
she on television by the way she's
fantastic
so thank you very much thank you
everybody
and I just want to go on to say we're
wrapping up but the speech we have a
country that isn't such bad the speech
isn't electric when the speaker tells
you by the way we're we're starting to
wrap up the speech people of North
Carolina than any Administration in
history and Mark knows this they all
know this North Carolina lost half of
its manufacturing jobs after the twin
disasters of NAFTA the worst trade deal
ever which I terminated and China's
entry into the World Trade Organization
in conclusion but after Decades of false
promises and bitter betrayals from other
politicians
I ended NAFTA they said I couldn't do it
and Mexico was not happy and Canada was
not happy and I replaced it with the
usmca that's Mexico and Canada the best
trade deal we ever made in our country's
history a giant win for North Carolina
as you all know and the workers folks
look at what I already have
but he's going to represent you long and
hard thanks to small fuzzy now trying to
renegotiate the deal with the Biden
Administration don't do it don't do it
Joe don't do it don't allow it to happen
because they took advantage of us for 30
years I withdrew from the job killing
trans-pacific partnership would have
destroyed your state to protect American
workers I placed stiff tariffs on
foreign aluminum and steel and safety is
there something going on here guys I
mean in all honesty what is happening
here stiff States right now I put 50
tariffs China was dumping steel all over
the place I don't think they'd like me
too much
we live by too simple but critical Rules
by American and higher American buy and
hire
and I stood up to China like no
president in history taking in billions
and billions and billions of dollars in
tariffs and taxes no other president
took in 10 cents they never did anything
they came in they raped and pillaged our
country raping and we never did anything
and we then gave 28 billion dollars to
our great Farmers because our farmers
were hit hard during the negotiation you
know China said we're not going to do
anything they thought that out left me
and say we're not going to do anything
for the farmers and the farmers came in
I'll never forget they came to the White
House
and I said don't worry we're going to
help you out I'll get some subsidy for
you during this or sir we don't want
subs if only group that ever said that
to me with the farmers we just want a
fair playing field a Level Playing Field
I'll never forget that I had 32 farmers
in they said all we want is a Level
Playing Field and I made the best deal
ever made for farmers and manufacturers
and that was the deal with China but
then when covet came in I don't talk
about it I don't even talk about it but
it's been an incredible deal for the
farmers
we wanted to do I asked Sonny Perdue the
secretary of agriculture how much have
they heard us and what kind of numbers
have they done
sure they've hurt us 12 billion in our
first year today about 14 to 16 billion
the second
so I said that's okay so I charged China
28 billion dollars and I gave it to the
farmers 28 billion and we had
and we had hundreds of billions left
over hundreds of billions of dollars
which came into the treasury we fought
for North Carolina and we won for North
Carolina and this November we're about
to fight and win for North Carolina once
again
one of the first things we will do is to
stand up for parents rights
it's time to finally and completely
break the radical left's corrupt
education cartel is he going to do the
teach transgender line guys let me know
in the chat a politician I never thought
of myself as a politician but I guess I
am right but think of it I'm I'm
actually talking that we're going to
stand up for parents rights can you
imagine saying that like 10 years ago
they'd say he said he's got I mean of
course he's going to stand up for
parents rights today it's like
politically it's somewhat Politically
Incorrect to even say it we are standing
up for parental rights
can't believe I have to even say can't
believe I have to say it our children
are captives
to unhinged Marxist Educators who are
pushing inappropriate sexual racial and
political material or sexually from the
youngest possible age at long last every
part
and every parent in America must be
empowered to opt out of indoctrination
and send their child to the public
private chart or religious or home
school of their choice they're going to
do that
in addition we will get critical race
Theory another Beauty it's coming it's
got to be coming out of our military I
took it totally out of our military they
put it back in
and out of every part of our federal and
state and local governments we will also
keep men the hell out of women's sports
right
keep men out of women's Force we're
gonna keep men out you see those records
are being broken at numbers that nobody
ever could think of
the weight lifters are hitting you know
if they they picked up one ounce they'd
be thrilled after years
but we're breaking records by 150 pounds
we'll break into swim records at numbers
1 8 of a second she wanted you know the
story I've told it off and I won't
bother telling it tonight but one day he
says tell it tell it
1 8 of a second but he broke the record
this giant this giant man she's looking
over she said who is this she doesn't
remember swimming against her
and she looks at this giant he had a
wingspan like Wilt the stilt Chamberlain
and he broke the record by 38 seconds
she just wanted to break it by 1 8 of a
second
and no teach you should ever be allowed
to teach transgender to our children
there it is whatever that means
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican Congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in America we don't have it
we have fake news we get a lot of fake
news and go out and sign up right now
with true social how good is true social
they're constantly trying to kill people
it's doing great it's a hot plastic I
think it's the hottest platform
and I wouldn't say Twitter's doing too
good he just said it's killing Twitter I
wouldn't say Twitter is doing too good
right now but truth sign up for True
truth we want the truth the radical left
Democrat Party is not a 50 party within
our country they're against God Guns oil
law enforcement voter ID tax cuts
regulation cuts the Constitution
and they're against our founding fathers
other than that I really think they're
terrific
Uncle Sam thinks they're fabulous
the way they win is to cheat in
elections I really believe that how can
you be against all of those things and
then say Oh we just we just nipped out
Trump we just whipped nipped
did he just say we nipped the Republican
party has a chance we must pass critical
election Integrity reforms including
Universal voting ID can you imagine they
don't want voting identification
And yet when they had their their big
convention they had like placards in
their front fingerprints pictures the
nose 15 different ways side
but they don't want voter ID because
they want to cheat now think of it can
you imagine they don't want voter ID
citizenship confirmation they don't want
that either we don't want to know
whether or not they're a citizen they
don't have to be a citizen Ted not too
many of those people are going to be
voting for you Ted or Mark or any of you
whatever your name is we want no more
fake drop boxes 417 million went into
those fake drop boxes and a lot of bad
decisions are coming out on the courts
about more the reality of those Rock
boxes and boxes and I have to tell you
that Wisconsin the state of Wisconsin
has been incredible what they've done on
showing the election fraud has been
incredible and so of other states no
private money pouring into local
election offices anymore and ultimately
we we need same day voting with only
paper ballots not for Trump he wants to
vote by mail a month early but
same day
but that's what we want
same day brother you know I have
some ladies from North Carolina over
there they've attended 92 rallies
stand up Liz
these people they're so beautiful I'm
not supposed you know you're not allowed
to say that anymore but you are
you know you're not allowed to talk
about a woman's Beauty
because it's Politically Incorrect but
look at them over there they come from
North Carolina and I I can be in Nevada
I can be in Texas I can and they've
attended 92 I don't know what it's doing
for your marriages they're married women
with handsome husbands the husbands are
here a little bit less but they come to
but they're incredible and I'm in your
state so I figure I have to give you a
shout out 92 rallies they've attended
people were starting to come and I think
they're I think they're very rich
actually I think they have to be rich to
attend that but look at the way they're
dressed look at the way they're
fantastic women and we will see you soon
okay we're working on something they
want to come to Mar-A-Lago I said you
know I think I'm going to let them what
the hell will happen present you long
and hard are you bringing your husbands
leave them home to hell with him this is
very sad it is they're great people
we're just seven weeks away where's
Front Row Joe
oh Front Road he's how many have you
been to you know he's they're looking at
92 as being like peanuts
that's great thank you darling thank you
very much right bro these are the front
Road shows they wait in line for five
six days to get in can you believe
because they want to be you believe this
Ted people got here five days ago are
you exhausted these are on the front row
we love you thank you very much
everybody we are just seven weeks away
from the most important midterm election
by the way if you missed it and you're
just joining us there was an incredible
audio disaster earlier further scream
that his days are numbers
[Music]
and in 2024 most importantly I gotta say
Ted I'm sorry but most importantly I
shouldn't say that Ted but most
importantly we're going to take back our
magnificent White House
[Music]
foreign
the crowd excited that it may soon be
the end of the rally clearly
together we will fight for more jobs for
North Carolina families fair trade for
North whoops sorry guys
even imagine just like we were doing
before factories will be forging more
products stamped with that beautiful
beautiful phrase Trump's been speaking
69 minutes that's not a joke actually
it's been 69 minutes this clearly is
going to be a shorter rally because he's
already getting to the climax and day
new mom
strengthen the Patriots of ice border
patrol border patrol what people
they're incredible people
and we will again and catch and release
we will end chain migration all things
we did before they just had to leave it
alone
we will end the Visa Lottery which is a
disaster we will clamp down on illegal
immigration just like we did less than
two years ago when we had again the
greatest strongest Border in the history
of our country we will stop the crime
wave in democrat-run cities and we will
give our police the power they need and
the respect they deserve
and we will never ever take legal
protection away from our police they
want to take legal protection they want
our police to go out and hire their own
lawyers can you believe these people
we will restore a thing called Law and
Order in America
we will hold China accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world we
will defend our constitution we will
defend the Second Amendment and we will
proudly uphold the judeo-christian
values and principles of our remember he
means Christian
when they say judeo-christian they're
just trying to try to pretend to be
inclusive of something other than
Christianity your children to love their
country honor our history and to always
respect our Great American flag
in conclusion our Mega make America
great again movement
to make America great again I told that
the other day I was saying please tell
Biden don't hit Maga it means make
America great again what's the hit
can you imagine they go after make
America great again but that tells you
sir it's by far the greatest political
movement in the history of our country
probably in the history of almost all
countries of all time together we are
standing up against some of the most
menacing forces entrenched interests and
vicious opponents our people have ever
ever seen
despite great outside dangers from other
countries our biggest threat Remains the
sick Sinister and evil people from
within our own country true but no
matter how big or powerful the corrupt
radical left Democrats are
we are
fighting like nobody's ever fought
before I I really believe that right now
we are fighting like nobody has ever
fought before and you must never forget
this nation does not belong to them this
nation belongs to you
and you
belongs to you
this is your home this is your heritage
and our American Liberty is your
god-given right they want to take God
out of politics no we're not taking God
from Asheville to Charlotte from
Greensboro to Raleigh and from Kitty
Hawk to right here at a place called
Wilmington have you ever heard of
Wilmington
this state was forged by some of the
toughest men and some of the strongest
women all right let me know in the chat
is Trump going to do the dance today I
know it's horrible but what do you think
Back Country farmers and Frontier
settlers incredible people Woodsman and
Craftsmen and workers and warriors who
poured their love into this land
for their families and above all they
were proud citizens fiercely independent
North Carolina Patriots who blazed their
own trail
and took orders from nobody
they forged the pathways they climbed
the mountains they fought the battles
they conquered the dangers and they
tamed the unknown Wilderness they built
the factories and they gave everything
they had to make America into the
greatest and most powerful Nation
in the history of the world
oh no
oh no
[Music]
but now we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation are the cute
people gonna do the salute as the
highest inflation in 50 years
and where the stock market finished the
worst first half of the year since 1872.
likewise we are wasn't it 1972 1872 that
doesn't sound right can anybody fact
check that longer energy 1872 dominant
as we just were two very short years ago
we are a nation that is yeah there's
people doing the the finger thing
and many other countries for oil please
please please help us as Joe Biden
look at this right under our feet than
any other country
we are a nation that is consumed by the
radical left's Green New Deal yet
everyone there's been no green New Deal
passed to our destruction
we are a nation whose leaders are
demanding all electric cars even though
they can't go far costs too much and the
reason we know the country is in a
downfall
is their recommending electric vehicles
the clear sign of the decline of America
right under our feet in the United
States but not available anywhere in
China we are a nation that ended oil
exploration and production in the United
States just as the price of oil reached
an all-time high
we are a nation that surrendered in
Afghanistan leaving behind dead soldiers
American citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
anywhere in the world
and we are a nation that allowed Russia
to devastate a country Ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people this is
crazy crazy fascist nonsense never have
happened with me as your
commander-in-chief and for four long
years it didn't happen and China with
Taiwan is next we are a nation that has
weaponized its law enforcement against
the opposing political party like never
before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election-changing facts to be presented
to the public where Hunter Biden's
laptop was Russian disinformation when
they knew it wasn't
and the Department of Justice that
refuses to investigate egregious acts of
voting irregularities and fraud
and we have a president who is caught
the fact that there are tens of millions
in this country that aren't obviously
disgusted by this tells us how bad
things have gotten in World War III
we are a nation that no longer has a
free
and fair press
fake news is all you get
and they are the enemy of the people
[Music]
where free speech is no longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been collapsing
where more people died of covet in 2021
than in 2020.
we are a nation that is allowing around
I'm about to cry too but for different
reasons I think China to use the
trillions and trillions of dollars it
has taken from us to build a military to
rival our own
and just two years ago we had Iran China
Russia and North Korea in check they
weren't going to do a thing against us
and everyone knows it
and perhaps most importantly we are a
nation that is no longer respected or
listened to around the world we are a
nation that in many ways he's really
focused in on that teleprompter huh
nation that is hostile to Liberty
freedom and faith
we are a nation whose economy is
floundering whose stores are not stocked
whose deliveries are not coming and
whose educational system is ranked at
the bottom of every single list
we are a nation whose once revered
airports are dirty and a crowded mess
where you sit and wait for hours and
then are notified that the plane won't
leave
does Trump know that in commercial
Aviation everybody's always waiting for
hours like that's kind of they tell you
show up and wait for hours please you're
required to wait for hours qualify air
traffic controllers and they don't know
what they're doing
we are a nation that has lost its
confidence
willpower and strength we are a nation
that has lost its way
but we are not going to let this
continue
two years ago we were a great nation
and we will soon be a great nation again
right
it was hard-working Patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working Patriots like you who are
going to save our country we will stand
up to the radical left lunatics and the
rhinos and we will fight for America
like no one has ever fought before there
is no mountain we cannot climb there is
no Summit we cannot reach there is no
challenge we cannot it's like low rent
fascism is basically the way I would
describe it that bend we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up and we will never
ever ever ever back down
as long as we are confident and United
the tyrants we are fighting do not stand
a chance because we are Americans and
Americans kneel to God and God Alone
my fellow you would think based on how
much this was ridiculed someone would
have gone to him and said sir
let's skip the music for our country
again
We Are One movement one people one
family and one glorious American Nation
so with the help of everyone here today
and citizens all across our land
we will make America powerful again
we will make America wealthy again
[Music]
[Applause]
we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again super
strong subscription dump there from
Espress
safe again
and we will make America great again
thank you God bless you thank you very
much North Carolina thank you
[Music]
well there he goes
[Music]
really depressing I mean just a low rent
fascism appealing to the lowest common
denominator
truly no other way to say it truly no
other way to say
I'm glad you joined me even if it was
extraordinarily disturbing
we have many streams coming up next week
oh God he's doing it again oh my
goodness he's sick on Wednesday the
January 6 Committee hearing on Friday
Beto O'Rourke versus Greg Abbott debate
assuming it has not been canceled or
will not be canceled and October 1st the
next Trump rally uh make sure you don't
miss any of it my friends any of it make
sure you are subscribed for free on our
YouTube channel where we are approaching
1.5 million subscriptions if we get
there by October 4th the day of Yom
Kippur I will fast I will actually do
the Yom Kippur fast which I have not
ever done before we also have launched
the Pacman Finance Channel and I would
love for you to check that out as well a
beautiful new channel
spiffy clean and everything else you
would hope for from a new channel folks
this was really
really
bad and scary
and again
Trump alone wouldn't be that scary
what's scary is all these people who
love this crap and think it's great when
it's just low rent fascism low rent
fascism truly horrible
so there goes Donald Trump I appreciate
everybody that joined me even if we are
seeing the decline of American
culture and thinking
uh we'll see everybody very soon all
right have a good night have a good
weekend
stay safe out there